the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
pieces were flying off the boards at the
St Louis rapid and Blitz with three
rounds under their belts players quickly
went to work despite only three decisive
games the entire day Frenchman Ola Reza
farusha found himself at the center of
the action once again after losing to
American Legend Fabiano caruana the
young Superstar stormed back into first
place after defeating linear Dominguez
in time pressure a three-headed monster
is right behind tied for second place
can the leader fend off his hungry
pursuers day three of heart racing chess
coming up next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
rapid and Blitz held at the St Louis
chess club It's the final day of Rapid
trust and the cream is starting to rise
to the top who is going to make the
final push and win the rapid section
let's go to the studio and find out with
Yasser and people
live from the sunny St Louis Home of the
First World Chess Championship welcome
to Rapid and Blitz from the St Louis
chess club
hello and welcome to day three of the
2019 store Rapid and Blitz event in St
Louis I'm Peter Switzer I can't speak
English and with me is yes it makes it
hard doesn't it Peter it is a problem
yeah it is a problem hello everyone and
Welcome to our live coverage of the
rapid and Blitz after six rounds of play
it's been a lot of fighting games just
not a lot of decisive results at least
not the results we expected Peter lay
the table for us and tell us about our
current standings after six rounds of
players absolutely with with three
rounds of Rapid lift we have alireza in
clear first uh up there at the top eight
points out of 12 with three players
chasing him on seven out of 12 including
uh
and the young American Jeffrey Sean then
the All-American part of the right paper
or stable yeah linear and Sam shankwood
on 50 same having made six draws out of
six so far
is very unexpectedly I would say below
50 on -1 and the chocolate
bringing up the rear they're having a
very poor event so far exactly and our
format for the event uh Peter the format
is a 10 player around Robin with the
rapid time control being 25 plus 10
second increment today is the last day
so the last three rounds will be played
today then we will play uh Blitz uh for
two days on Monday and Tuesday draw for
is not allowed and the scoring system as
you can see on your screen rapid games
count double so today is a very
important day to perhaps try and put
some uh Blue Sky between you and your
pursuers and for the blitz we will go
back to the usual one point to win half
a point for a draw and our remaining
schedule uh the schedule is pretty
straightforward today is round seven
through nine uh over the rapid and then
on Monday and Tuesday we will play a
full round robin per day of Blitz
with colors reverse compared to Monday
of course there will be playoffs uh if
necessary if there is a typo first on
Tuesday and the closing ceremony to
follow shortly after and as always we
have our friend Christian
Studios we see the players entering the
playing Hall and getting wanded uh
Christian you're gonna tell us about our
leader Ali Reza farouza and his road
ahead good to see you my friend
you guys great to be back in the studio
calling the action calling the games of
the best rapid and Bliss chess players
that we have on the planet and what a
fantastic event it has been up to this
point but one star that is shining
bright is that of Ali Reza firuja the 19
year old from France who is just
impressing the audience with his result
up to this point what a fantastic young
man this one is and let's take a look
how he got to where he is right now at
the top of the leaderboard he started
off with two important victories bam bam
in round number one and to after that he
slowed down a little bit and a very
difficult defeat with the white pieces
against far piano karuana his Kryptonite
in round number five but immediately
bounced back with an incredible Victory
with the black pieces against the
struggling Lanier Dominguez that just
showed that he is in a great state of
mind being able to come back and bounce
back with an important Victory after an
immediate painful defeat and let's take
a look at his road ahead well today he
has a very difficult road ahead of
himself round number seven against a
surging
he is only one point behind Ali Reza so
this one definitely a very important
round for both of these players after
that in round number eight against Levon
aronian who is struggling in this event
up to this point nevertheless still
three rounds to go three rounds of Rapid
chess and in round number nine against
his compatriot Maxim vashir lagraven
let's take a look at the standings and
how all the players got to where they
are today first of all Ali res after
round number one he was in pole position
and kept it all the way until today
Lanier Dominguez a big victory against
the struggling Hikaru Nakamura as you
can see at the bottom of the standing
see Karu only zero points Fabiano
carawana started off with a draw and
let's take a look what happened after
day one after three rounds of play still
alireza with Five Points uh topping the
leaderboard two victories and one draw
that third round against Sam Shanklin
was just an incredible game mvl and
Lanier Dominguez as well as the surging
youngster Jeffrey Sean the Wild Card
going into this event doing quite well
up to this point and let's take a look
at what happened after a day two still
Ali Reza at the top a crucial victory in
round six against Lanier Dominguez
mvl and Jeffrey Sean still tied for the
second position we see a surging yanepo
miyashi and if you are the field you
don't want to see that man surging
through the rankings we know how streaky
he can get we have an amazing day three
of Rapid action ahead of ourselves thank
you Christian as always for your
insights and Peter set the table for our
viewers what can the pairings bring us
for round seven absolutely in round
seven there is a bunch of very
interesting pairings with the field as
star started as this is uh we always
have that but uh up there yeah our
tournament leader playing uh the white
pieces uh against one of his closest
pursuers uh ferozanichi is completely
clearly the peak of of the round and
then we have the usual uh fantastic
pairings everywhere else live on his
wife against Lanier MBL versus 5B is
another very very interesting game to
watch uh Shakira White against Jeffrey
Sean and Hikaru is playing against Sam
Shanklin they've worked together
recently so it would be interesting to
to watch them compete against each other
absolutely importantly alireza starts
with two whites today he's white against
uh Ian and Ron in round one of the day
and in round eight he will also be white
against Lebon so if he gets the devil
yeah important for him to try and
perhaps increase his lead in those two
games all this Fighting Chess and what
are they fighting for
the price funding the rapid events in
the GCT uh stays at 175
000 total with 40 Grand going to the
winner 34 second place in 25 for third
and going all the way down to seven as
you can see on your screen for the the
person finishing last and the GST points
which form a separate purse to be
awarded after the entire tour is done uh
12 or 13 depending on whether you win a
Dodge right or on tie break for the
winner thank you Peter for all of that
as we get a view of the playing haul as
the players are getting ready uh taking
their seats uh you see Lanier entering
and getting wanded and new electronic
devices absolutely none whatsoever
now you mentioned the tasty game between
farrugia and Jan uh if you're faruger
you'll wipe if you play one E4 you're
gonna expect the petrol probably yeah
you would assume that uh Jana's program
yeah probably should not be you know
deviating from the ultra solid
repertoire who's built for the world
championship match when he's playing
Black against the tournament leader I
would expect him to go uh to go E5 and
to go for the petrol exactly there is a
place everything on that one so we're
not right like money for is Livonia is
very very restrained today yeah I was
about to say where's this with his
tutorial choices yeah I mean he looks
looks fantastic as usual but you know a
plane a plain shirt like Hello Maybe
maybe we're spoiled maybe maybe today's
laundry day and everything else is just
being washed good point good point and
my pick for winning the event is akara
Nakamura uh Sam Shanklin drawn as you
mentioned all of his games that I find
that remarkable but equally I find it
remarkable that uh hikaru's languishing
yeah it is it is very unexpected I think
uh you know he won this event very
convincingly
uh generally this is very much you know
his bread and butter the rabbit and
Blitz events there are still 18 games
and even the rapid honestly like he is
not doing well but he's only three
points behind the tournament leader
which is something that could actually
be uh
uh he could caught up during today if
alireza has an off day and he has a very
nice day but we'll see yeah as you can
see no Petrov understandably that's
where I was leading yeah I wanted to
lead you there to this idea that if I
play E4 and if unless I have some really
really outstanding preparation for a
Petrov maybe I want to play in English
and maybe you want to play Queen party
just take the there's also there's also
Waters perhaps I mean it's it's very
very sort of long-term ideas which I
don't know if if they form you know a
large part of
these players uh preparation but you
have to have at least like half an eye
on the upcoming singfield Cup right if
you do have a you know a quote-unquote
kill already against the Petrov you want
to maybe save it yeah both of them I
assume are playing in this thing I think
though I mean they're both full tour
participants so uh I mean you're not
guaranteed to get white against Young
and the singfield couple but the
bearings has not been have not been done
yet but perhaps you you choose something
else for for the rapid templates we have
a Queen's Gambit uh with the Four
Knights a2a3 I've had a lot of
experience with these positions uh uh on
both sides actually uh A7 A6 used to be
my choice A6 A6 is a way is a way to
play there DC4 is not a mistake or no
but but this is uh uh well very
different in spirit this starts looking
a little bit like the The Queen's Gambit
accepted but yes but there are
definitely subtle differences between
this agree in the classical qgas because
we have already developed a knight to C6
as well as Knights as well as an iPhone
C3 which uh which definitely is uh I
mean in spirit this is all obviously
very very qga qga adjacent right let's
put it like this but it's uh it's it's
not exactly the same Queen C2 is a very
uh unusual move to my house Queen C2 in
a very concrete one I'm assuming the
point is that we maybe in some positions
are now threatening to take on C5 and
then to take on B5 using the the X-ray
along the C file here well let's uh
invite Chris Christian to join the
discussion in this move Queen C2 for
both uh Peter and I Christian we're this
is off the Beaten Track for us it all
started with Bishop to A2 first of
course after A6 Castle is the big line
they take C5 inviting the end game as
well quite a big line Bishop to A2 not
so much it has been seen only once in a
game uh in 2020 between poncratov and
zalmakanov ramazan I hope I uh spelled
that correctly Bishop to A2 B5 was the
move chosen in that game as well and
nepo by the way responded immediately so
he was definitely aware of what he needs
to do but indeed after Queen 2c2 Castle
is by far the engine's uh move a queen
to C2 seems to be forcing matters right
now C takes D4 is one way but it does
seem that after he takes D4 or maybe
even Knight takes before you have to
accept almost the pawn sacrifice and if
you do that after take take a castle
Knight D5 is also a move now taking
advantage of the fact that the queen is
on C2 and I can immediately go to C6
with devastating consequences and a very
very complicated position I have to say
a lot of compensation for for black as
well this is going to be very intriguing
to see how it develops if you do go go
Bishop to B7 you have to tend with the
fact that I can take take and now
there's all these sorts of Knight takes
B5 uh in the position and potentially
creating some Havoc it does seem that
after Knight takes B5 Knight to D7 black
still has plenty of compensation due to
the fact that this [ __ ] Pawn B7 is so
powerful and you still haven't castled
you still haven't finished your
development as why the bishop on A2 is
not really on it when ready to
potentially challenge the a light Square
Bishop on the long diagonal it's a bit
far far away from and in the meantime
the pawn sacrifice has actually been
accepted so it's very it has it's very
interesting to see uh yes and 95 the
move you mentioned 95 has been bleached
out yes Queen C5 seems to be the best
move right now Bishop to E3 or King to
F1 uh both of them seem to be contenders
in the position so for example we can
see something along the lines of this
King to d8 uh not Queen takes A8 but
Bishop to uh D2 first now the question
is why because after Bishop to C5 seems
that you don't have enough time to
actually get your pieces into play Rook
to E8 followed by Queen to E2 is coming
really quick and your queen is also a
little bit out of play also I feel that
I have ideas against the pawn on F2 with
the bishop on C5 it's dangerous but it
does seem that alireza knows exactly
what he's absolutely wow absolutely
trying to remember the variation because
he's aware of what of this variation
yeah this is a look of a man who has
seen this position on his screen but
probably not today yes maybe like six
months ago yeah and it if it's not today
positions like this can be extremely
dangerous because in a way it's whoa
okay in a way it's actually better
perhaps in some cases not to know
anything at all instead of trying to uh
trying to recall what your screen told
you because unless yarn has a much more
powerful engines this is a very very bad
move yeah this seems to be a a somewhat
puzzling choice in particular having
played with this at this speed exactly
because yeah 26 Queen take Queen takes
A8 appears to be borderline losing right
now a question for you the key being
that after Without a Queen on E5 after
Queen to C6
King to d8 I'm going to meet that with
Bishop to G5 first
I'm throwing in that picture
and then we can maybe even include Rook
jivan yeah F6 Bishop takes D5 or Rook to
D1 but I think Bishop takes D5 is
actually just winning right now
this is the key with the queen on E5 you
don't have this setup to finish your
development as a white but Bishop to G5
with a Tempo followed by Bishop takes D5
seems to be decisive right now
uh where's the novelty uh thus far uh
Quinto was a novelty at least according
to my database Queen City Bishop to A2
was played only once and after B5 uh
Castle the most natural response was
that would be transposing to a position
which is quite known but yeah is a new
is a new approach and yeah yeah you
never exactly know what's what's going
on with you circulating there yeah with
his reactions to uh the Novelties
because uh he clearly put a lot of
thought into his new repertoire you know
he used to be a hardcore grenfell player
and he's no longer really is a hardcore
grenfield player but uh check check
Yan's reaction guys yeah and queen C6
and it was a sour face wasn't it I think
yes he clearly didn't want documentary
six I think while alireza was double
checking his uh his understanding of
what's going on perhaps Jan figured out
a fault with his original plan but then
why do you play so quickly is exactly
yeah seven okay king2d8 would have been
pretty much game over after Bishop G5 so
King E7 is the best move yes on the
board and inviting Queen takes a a well
shall we uh Peter um I think yeah I
think Yan was perhaps hoping that Queen
E4 check does a lot it does something
after taking it but I I guess it just
doesn't do enough because white has
Bishop 53 yes yeah and queen takes G2
long castles I assume we just resign
because once the white king is safe I
mean white has more pieces more attack
More Everything more everything and more
everything so Black's King is on an open
Highway here
possibly but then after King F1 it's
just a much much uh worse version
because we uh you know more Bishop C5
yeah the king is only seven E7 instead
of G8 we took with the Knight instead of
the pawn so we don't have the open E
file to look forward to in the future
exactly
it just looks extremely dodgy it looks
like you might just not get out of the
opening here objectively this is losing
already yeah yeah with the King and he's
I mean especially uh I don't I might
have something to argue if I could play
a move like Bishop C5 or Bishop D6
absolutely but just the fact that my
Bishop is hanging what am I going to do
uh drop back with the queen that looks
that looks horrible Bishop D7 but then
like there are so many problems with
this I mean the the end game of the
Queen Bishop takes D5 and uh and just
because he thinks if I think you get
made out of the bishop G2 so you
probably have to take with the queen but
if you take with the queen I mean that
end game is horrible
it will continue for a while but you
most likely will lose it and there's
probably more more ambitious ways to do
it with white as well it's the worst
like uh I'm an exchange app and you've
got this worse bishop and pawn uh Duo uh
everything about Yan's play has been
questionable and he's played so quickly
uh Peter I've seen Jan throughout his
career playing very very quickly
beautiful chess and sometimes it's uh I
mean today I think what is happening uh
at least my guess is that uh as uh vasil
evanchuk once many many years ago
actually wasn't DaVinci himself it was
his coach for that tournament I beat him
in in Dortmund 98 and he did something
quite strange straight out of the
opening against me there in Spanish an
opening he understands like very very
few others yeah and he did something
which was frankly kind of inexplicable
and did not survive after that and I
asked his trainer what was that and and
he just kind of looked at me and said
wrong page
wrong page wrong pages
this really looks like a case of a wrong
wrong page page there was a picture in
Jan's mind of some line in which this 95
tactic exists and he remembered that
there is some position where you can go
Knight takes D5 and you're fine it's
just it's not this position it is not it
doesn't really look like it's this
position yeah Queen E5 check played and
yeah we left the king of one you're just
in a lot of trouble and yet Jan
continues to play as if this is all part
of I mean again he's got 23 minutes in
time right Christian yeah it just feels
like you have to Bluff a little bit at
this point
that you just forgot your theory yeah I
still like wrong page uh what else is
going on in this round I mean we started
with a bang over here but I'm sure uh it
was a game of Lavon and Lanier which was
crazy yeah that one is definitely crazy
as well there's a few end games actually
this one between Mom and the arrow and
Jeffrey started off very similar uh to
the one between nepo and Ali Reza but
instead of e3 it takes D5 was played in
that one and we've seen this variation
so many times E4 is one of the ways
actually my media of uh pressured Hikaru
in their direct encounter in this end
game after E4 and he decided to repeat
that Bishop to G5 is also a big move
right now E4 and this is what we have
right now so white sacrificed upon
momentarily of course you will just
simply take it back on e4 which
immediately happened King to E7 this is
the current position but it does feel
like Jeffrey this looks completely fine
yes Jeffrey was just simply much better
prepared than Hikaru in that game a
mediev actually got on almost winning
position not in this one this one seems
to be just going and we do have yeah if
we if we continue perhaps slightly
unfairly uh if we continue calling this
line the Berlin of one G4 we have the
Berlin of ones before and we also have
an actual Berlin in this round there is
exactly the game between mvl and Fabiano
and this one well it does seem like
white is still harboring hopes for an
advantage but not not much yeah there's
not much uh fork and game there's not a
lot of weaknesses I understand I don't
have a majority on this side an active
majority on the queen side as black and
you could say that okay I'm pulling up
on the king side that's why nevertheless
I don't feel this is going to be enough
I think this one is within the grasp of
equality for carwana and as you guys
were mentioning this is the big one all
right versus Dominguez and it does seem
like Iranian is playing super fast
sacrificed uh why one pawn and this
position according to the engine is
quite good for black nevertheless from a
practical perspective with so many
things and so many cannons coming your
way Rook 2 F1 Rook to G1 also this
Knight potentially if you allow me to
take on e4 and start swarming around the
king it can become dangerous from a
practical perspective I have to say I
like erroneous chances forget about the
eval of the engine in this one okay but
continue that exact position I've been
anxious to ask you well what will happen
after E5 takes D4 E5 takes D4 Knight
takes E4 Queen F5 Queen to F5 now I can
take and actually I'm already better as
white no way right okay well a little
bit and he takes different and he takes
D4 this majority on the queen side seems
to be more efficient than the majority
on the king side for black really I'm
stunned Bishop takes E4 Rook takes E4 F5
yes I thought I was getting my Pawn
going yeah I think black is fine but
black is definitely as is why the I
think the interesting point is that I
will I will check the timings uh for a
sec but I'm pretty sure that linear
actually bleeds everything up out uh up
to it including quintex F2 yeah so wow
they both were very happy very happily
aiming for pretty much the same position
and Rook D1 is the first move that uh
rupee eight is an interesting idea here
stopping Knight takes E4 of course by
attacking upon on bitsu and perhaps
planning to meet Queen take C5 not
perhaps definitely playing the mid Queen
takes E5 with Rook takes B2 which
probably wins on the sport by the way
this is a big moment right now because
white does have the option of forcing a
Perpetual against the queen with Rook to
F1 Rook to F1 you probably have to take
on H2 and then I can just go to H1 Queen
F2 root to F1 and uh so on and so on
appears to be a good idea yes a bail if
you don't do that it does seem like
black is getting a much better position
so let's wait and see what Levon who
surely is aware of this uh move of this
variation will decide to do will
continue or will he bail and I think
that the big Point here and the big
point of difference between what we were
just discussing and this is I thought
why not just play b2b3 and then I
realized that now we go he takes D4 and
take off and you can no longer you can
actually Queen A2 Knight F6 check
but maybe this is fine for black somehow
gf6 that's a knife GF from G1 Bishop G4
that's very nice so if you go B3 take on
D4 Knight takes you cannot take on A2
because of Knight to F6 it's still a
mess I mean it's still a mess we're
discussing it on the large board and I I
don't see the immediate mate and with
black also has plenty of checks coming
so maybe you can actually still do it
shockingly wow it's just GF and Bishop
G4 yes
so in fact there's no play if b2b3 is in
the future yeah and this is why this is
what because my first reaction was why
are we playing root B8 B3 looks like a
perfectly sensible move why are we so
unhappy about it with white but there is
definitely a very concrete reason why uh
playing B3 is detrimental to to wise
chances exactly
well there just doesn't seem any choice
then yeah none of you probably have to
go for that that line that Christian was
outlining yeah and finally uh the game
between uh Hikaru and Sam shankland
yeah this one is a mess my first
reaction was I was going to say I very
much like black but
um in fact perhaps there's yeah I still
feel like them I think you're right I
think the Knight on the floor will be
just so annoying for uh for what I like
nice H2 and F3 I I sort of I hated
White's position much more when there
was a knight out of three and the entire
construction wasn't really going
anywhere right but now that Hikaru found
this uh
restructuring with Knight h2f3 follow
but perhaps by Bishop F2 and Bishop F2
in particular is going to be a bit of an
annoying move to face because day seven
is hanging and if you play B6 you're
very much playing into a 485 ideas
exactly exactly but
how effective will that be and how
probably not very questions right the
the drawback of course is this uh very
glaring on D3 sorry Kristen so Knight to
F4 Bishop to F2 let's go B6 which
actually are moves played on the board
right now yep
A4 right well probably yeah nothing else
really makes any sense yeah well again
should I be making
um a concession with Knight I think C4 I
think if we play Slowly here we're just
not going to enjoy our position at all
yeah I think we we have to at least try
being quick here and play for okay but
now how
am I supposed to
oh I can play D4
right yes I can actually think twice
exactly Rook uh 1992 check as uh is a
bail perfect but that's a problem that
is a very large problem actually yeah so
I guess you don't have time for A4 you
have to defend with Rook D1 first yeah
and Rook D1 Rook D1 Queen E6
I keep attacking yeah it's just it just
continues being extremely awkward even
let's say if six Bishop F7 to follow and
then I will start looking at some H5 G4
ideas just to open stuff yeah I'm trying
to get in my A4 A5 that you'll be
getting in your H5 G4 yeah uh who gets
there first with the most is what that's
going to be all about uh an exciting
game for sure let's let's just check
back in uh with our first and second
place uh players alireza Giannis finally
finally stopped stop stop blitzing but
uh the damage is done yeah it really
does feel like he had some kind of a
mental image of some position where this
exchange sacrifice was working
and uh
just played too quickly and is now
realizing that this probably isn't it
this was not what we had intended uh I'm
I'm really grasping at straws so forgive
me here on this one Knight B6 Queen A7
check King F6 Queen takes B6 Bishop C5
by the way I you know I can't really
shake off those uh those habits I saw a
very very beautiful line in chat oh and
I want to go it's it's way past it's way
past us but it's just such a beautiful
line instead of King F1 Chad suggested
King D1 oh and now after uh King F6 yes
Queen takes C8 Bishop B4 Bishop yeah I
get the feeling white is still winning
perhaps after Quincy too but the line
that I wanted to show because of how
beautiful it is and perhaps some of our
viewers have not seen this Motif earlier
Queen takes h8 of course Queen D4 check
okay now you have to go towards the uh
Heights actually yeah yeah so King he
took because King C2 is quite easily
getting mated but King itso we go Queen
E4 check okay Bishop B3 okay and it
looks like we've defended ourselves but
after Knight F4 uh oh we still get made
unfortunately but I wanted to show was
King F1 and then the the smother it made
but Queen takes G2 is mate in one which
is very very disappointing but yeah show
the one yeah this is uh yeah this is the
one I wanted and this is why I brought
up the entire line it's just such a
beautiful beautiful finish when did you
first when were you first shown
smothered mate like this because for me
it was like an epiphany it was like wow
how spectacular I can't remember exactly
I mean it was obviously ages and ages
ago but every time you see this
construction and it actually is like a
semi-correct variation that has some
relevance right which is very you know
rare outside of uh constructed studies
because in Practical games you generally
don't see this I just wanted to show
this one before because no it's
beautiful this final you know boxed in
construction with both Rooks being used
to give mate to the King on G1 I thought
was worth our slight detour absolutely
absolutely for me Peter uh I was at that
point in my chess career where my queen
was everything like I played with my
queen I knew what I was doing when I
lost my queen I lost the game so
voluntarily giving up my queen never
never never when I showed this smothered
mate I ran home to show it to my mom who
was washing the dishes and she said very
good son can I go back
it was too beautiful very nice so what
is nepo going to do Christian I've ran
out of ideas I I think right now he's
just suffering
um this is it this is the only thing he
can do in this position because
objectively he's lost so he's clutching
is where is his uh how do you say best
Cheapo best Cheapo yeah that's a good
question I mean queen to D4 seems to be
a move Knight I think he's playing King
to D7 maybe from a practical perspective
just to try to finish your development
the problem is Queen to D4 by the way is
on the board Queen D4 on the board this
is his best Cheapo how do you like him
right I mean now I have a couple of
options as white I can go G3 obviously I
have to uh again one Bishop to G5 is
also a move yes well Bishop the G5 F6
but this looks completely lost right
yeah this is over right so I have to
defend the bishop with King to D7 ah
okay right and now you take probably on
D5
this is a main game that most likely
white is just going to be easily winning
so he takes my five and this one is yeah
looks pretty bad I have to say guys you
know it doesn't seem like nepo is going
to be surviving at this one just a big
mistake in the opening and that's all it
took
wow uh for for me to see a player who's
about to play for the World Chess
Championship being lost after just a
mere dozen moves but you could see his
page after Knight takes D5 Queen to C6
he did not want to see that move on the
board immediately after Knight to D5 I
think he realized that in his file Queen
to E5 was the move to protect against
Bishop to G5 yeah I think the he played
King E7 Queen E5 check quite quickly so
it feels like it really feels to me that
he remembered that there was some
position where his Queen was only five
and he was giving and he was giving up
that that exchange on A8 right and he
just took on D5 Without Really dwelling
too much on move orders but move orders
are incredibly crucial here exactly I
should have been Queen D4 on the board
were expecting Bishop G5 we're expecting
for farrugia what a new crucial Victory
it is he came into today's round at one
point in the lead and he will be
knocking backwards uh one of his key
Rivals as well so a big big game and
what else is the only thing that he can
do Jan that is after Bishop G5 King D7
Bishop takes D5 just go into that end
game yeah and try to try to survive
yeah alireza sometimes makes uh makes
technical tasks uh look harder than they
are because you know he's he's much
obviously as someone who has been in
this situation once or twice over the
course of my career when you get a good
position like this in particular when
you surprise your opponent with a bit of
interesting idea out of the opening you
would very much like for the game to end
in some kind of amazing attack exactly
and not have to you know spend 40 moves
carefully converting some kind of an
extra exchange right uh and your
attention might start drifting uh and
honestly like it will require some work
I will Queen D5 if we assume Queen takes
D5 is the best move which I think it is
it takes D5 I will put one Bishop on B7
the other one either on D6 or perhaps on
B6 if you played before I think Bishop
before is a logical move here to try to
put some pressure on the C7 square but I
play I play Bishop C5 here Rook C1
Bishop B6
I put the other one on B7 and I mean
it's bad of course it is no argument
this is like I'm not trying to make this
is how you give your opponent a chance
to go wrong yeah but uh in particular if
black manages the thing that bothers me
the most here I think with black is the
move Bishop P3
because yes yeah because now after G4 I
can take on D4 and go Rook D1 and that's
just completely hopeless and both
choices like abandoning the G4 Square
for the white bishop or trading one of
my Bishop bear both both seem very very
depressing exactly
uh the problem is that once my Pawn is
on the e-file I can also hook the D5
Pawn with E4 later on yeah and by the
way we do have Bishop G5 check King D7
on the board yeah all of this all of
this has been played yeah it's uh the
question is what alireza wants to take
on D5 for whether he will look for
something stronger but Bishop C5
actually is a legitimately very strong
threat you would like to play Rook C1
but after Rook C1 Bishop C5 perhaps
black is suddenly not even worse exactly
I mean even better if you compare the
pieces also it makes sense to exchange
the bishop Pawn A2 which is not a very
active and good piece with a knight on
D5 which is absolutely yes it's kind of
covering the D file as well as the C7
Square yeah all right uh we're gonna
leave uh this position and uh jump
around where would you like to take us
Peter
um uh
we're being there's some suggestions
that uh we should take a look at Shaq
and yeah I I think yeah I think uh this
is still not that something happened
yeah something went wrong here I'm a bit
surprised by the fact that Jeffrey chose
to reply to A3 with F5 I thought he
could quite safely just play Bush by
five
instead of that not really have to
calculate very much at all five I guess
he was worried about Knight C5
but I just in this case even if you take
it yeah it's just very difficult for me
to believe that this could be any
trouble whatsoever I agree and if it's
not Knight C5 if you have to play
something like Bishop C4 yes I will play
Rook 88 and I will play 95 or maybe we
should be six followed by 95 or
something like this and that'll be fine
yeah I don't think I don't think you can
be much worse F5 also looks logical but
it does allow this this idea by Shah of
very uh quickly attacking the black
center and now Rook GA we're caught up
to the play yeah at least it has become
very concrete I still don't really
understand why black needs to be you
know necessarily so much worse but so
what if I take on E5 exactly
95.4 I don't particularly like I see
Knight f4s
that that's unfortunate yeah
somehow okay let's go Knight G4 here try
to re-establish it on E3
4 yeah there is ah you don't have F4
because the Rook on G8 is still hanging
uh this yeah I just completely missed
94. I thought I will be open the highway
to your king yeah yeah
uh okay so uh shackriar who's really
been languishing as well at the bottom
of the table maybe he can uh
Pierce Jeffrey's armor Jeffrey uh
undefeated undefeated so far yeah kind
of shockingly considering how solely
this line is supposed to be second
second game in the row where shock uh he
is much better by move 20 or 22 in this
line which is supposedly
just a raw Croc solid per setup for like
an fv5 played yeah so as expected
Jeffrey Jeffrey now has a kind of an
unpleasant choice between Rook G2 Knight
IV which is not losing I don't think it
heals but it feels very very dangerous
or all the position we were discussing
and mvl and I think this one is about
then yeah it looks like it will shortly
end in a draw finally uh Caro desperate
for victory let's just uh we left it
right about here by the way uh no A4 but
Rook D1 C5 actually quite like C5 yeah
it breaks the structure further apart
and you will see in a moment the way uh
Sam has played at cb4c before and now
Bishop B7 rugby three Rook G4 that feels
much nicer followed by Rooker hd8
everything is hanging the before Pawn is
hanging the G3 Pawn will be hanging in a
moment
this looks terrible potentially just
straight up bad for hikara I think it's
terrible yeah and what is this Knight
doing on H2 well you can trade it for
the bishop now I think if you play
Knight G4 because of the ah Knight takes
E5 is not even a threat I can play 26 if
I want terrible because there's 92 in
the end as usual yeah I thought I can
play Knight takes E5 but it just loses a
piece but what if I just take on G4 yeah
also that yeah well it's it's a matter
of fact I'm not even going for your
d-pawn I think I'm going to go H5 and
made here that also is a problem yeah
additional additional problem of getting
mated on the king side this this looks
horrifying uh Hikaru looks uh terrible
terrible and did we see a repetition
oh wow he's gone into a 10 minute tank
more more than 10 minutes I think that's
about 15 by this point I think he he
started with 23 minutes yeah so that's
15. that's 15-ish yeah wow
after a 15-minute burn we did see the
move Rook H1 yeah you really don't have
anything better because Rook takes B2
remains a very strong threat exactly so
the exchange sacrifices well it's not
even a sacrifice Rook B2 is just uh
crushing and game over pretty much yeah
so it looks like you have to chase and
black probably also having opened up
some some files in front of your king
you probably don't want to be yeah you
don't want to yeah exactly you don't
want to encourage any uh Rook G1 takes
G7 kind of action so we do expect a
rapid
um repetition in this game and again I
just I I'm kind of stunned actually that
uh and the key right now is that you
don't have time to take on E5 at that
point right I'm sorry
exactly yeah Queen E5 would have been a
very attractive move the moment the
queen leaves the the diagonally if you
could play Queen takes C5 here you'd be
very interested and that's the key
behind Rook to be it's a move that you
don't want to see as why because it just
forces your hat absolutely yeah yeah it
just limits the options so severely that
yeah it feels like uh yeah LeBron has
already played Rook H1 I think he knows
and this is why he thought for so long
because he found this very interesting
uh fresh idea and he was perhaps hoping
to catch a linear someone wears and I
think he succeeded but linear spent some
time spent some time found a decent
decision as Christian mentioned the
computers don't really agree at least at
surface level with Lewan's idea but I'm
guessing he was very much hoping for
some kind of a disbalanced position even
if the evaluation appears to suggest
that black is doing completely fine but
should be ages kills the entire idea of
stone dead because yeah if the best you
have is an immediate draw by repetition
then yeah you're not very happy by the
way just as you prescribed it Peter
[Music]
um
sorry uh nepo did go for uh the the
queen takes D5 right and I quite like
the idea of B5 before by the way you do
trying to open up some files trying to
limit the uh like your dream you might
still lose but your dream is four
against three right your dream is to be
only left with the pawn on D5 and the
three on the queen on the king side
versus three on the king side okay and
yeah even those are going to be if the
if the dark Square Bishop bear comes off
the board right even those are going to
be really really unpleasant and perhaps
lost okay but that's I think the the
absolute uh you can strive for at least
unachievable dream yeah Bishop D4 like
Rook C8 interestingly he doesn't want to
spend any time defending weaknesses
which is interesting with uh defending
we ah maybe there was something uh uh
empowered me it might have been that he
he just some sort of H4 okay three might
be extremely annoying here yeah
absolutely yeah yeah these I still I
still would be kind of interested with
white in in the idea of picking up a
Pawn on the king side and then very much
so continuing on my Merry way I don't
see any reputation I think we can take
if Rook C2 I think we just go back
allowing Bishop C5 would would be a
mistake here but we just go back we
solidly block everything by Bishop D4 I
guess he won't say five which Basics B2
some kind of counter play like that but
that seems slow
yes it does that seems slow even though
you do generate some activity if we're
entirely honest with ourselves like I
don't know G3 or H4 whichever one you
like I give a check I force euroka away
from the G file you play let's say Rook
A1 and I want to play something like
Rook C4 and claim that my Pawn gets the
G3 and if it gets 33 you know it's a
it's a bit of a difference there's a
tickle and something like that there's
actually three I mean we're probably
still losing but yeah yeah you you
you're at least forcing yeah I go
deformation before a b yeah I get the
pawn to G3 I play Rook C2 and I claim
that you know I I'm seeing outlines of
how my position could improve and
possibly save the game and by the way uh
uh alireza said you know what I like
fans a lot
but I also like development uh h2h4 and
his intention is Crystal Clear he wants
to play Rook H3 and develop uh that away
so let's just continue the game Rook C2
yeah
and I like where you were driving a
moment ago Peter a light at least I was
forcing and by the way now I can also
play G6
before with the Rook on h8 there was no
G6 business yeah that is fair that is
fair we can we can actually spend the
tempo on on G6 now and uh end of the
world ah maybe Rook but then I go A5
yeah
I think he actually has reasonable uh
reasonable drawing chances now I think
he's been defending remarkable and there
we have it G7 G6 he said yes this you I
offered the pawn you refused it I'll
keep it this reminds me of their game I
think it was a Warsaw or Zagreb in which
once again alireza got the completely
winning position out of the opening and
then yarn just simply slowly slowly
pushed back into the game and uh drew
that game this is exactly what's
happening right now I'm starting to
think that Jan actually has better
chances to make a drawing this one than
Ali Reza has to win this wow yeah I mean
definitely definitely statement the
trend is very much in Jan's favor and
this setup with the root consider the
bishopon before followed by A5 which
Basics at an opportune moment it's
actually quite difficult to shake off
you would like to play Bishop C3
but the reconcito is so active it
doesn't really solve every single
problem and Bishop C5 is also always
going to be quite annoying in reply uh
legit said so what if I try to put the
Rook on E3
sorry A question put the record either
oh sorry excuse me uh G6 I probably
don't have enough time to go H5 and try
to invade with the rugby at the age well
well the problem is E7 well by the way
E7 and E1 are covered so Bishop F6 I I'm
not feeling no no no what I want to do
is actually just control the E2 Square
so that whenever you go Bishop to E2 I
go Rook to A1 you don't have this move
Rook to C for this place that is fair
yeah
but sort of a larger question at some
point uh perhaps is just how are you
going to make progress so let's look at
G4 let's say
even though yeah it's not hanging yeah
it might actually work fire yeah you
know G4 is hanging I don't like this G3
okay
check checking G2
yeah I'm thinking maybe I kind of want
to throw in h7h5 but okay let's go
between okay one and then something yeah
well can I bring my Bishop over there
yeah I I hate how much time we're
spending on this but it's a very solid
solid to E4
I mean I I really feel uh so much a
greater sense of relief yeah
penetration Square
squares for my Rooks as white I I really
don't like this yes it's going to be
very very difficult to win it's it's wow
it's going to be very difficult to win
you get the feeling that perhaps alireza
could have been like starting from the
position after the immediately after the
queen trade he probably had some ways to
you know not allow The Rook to land on
C2 it feels like you know if you look at
this position and we say you know five
moves later the black Rook will be on C2
and white will achieve no progress yeah
of course you want your Rooks on C1 and
E1 so if you start with let's say H4 and
Rook H3 you're pretty sure you're going
to get one Rook on the C file and one
Rook on the e-file and by the way Rook
F3 F5 got tossed in uh as well let me
just refresh my board for a quick second
and bring our position up to date
um well sometimes
you just gotta bear down and save the
position as best you can and that's what
we're seeing here by so let's take a
move by move let's go H5 and try to
Target that G6 yeah I think we actually
need to start generating some play of
our own with white here because if we
don't do that now we might not be able
to do it in here at all not being
entirely later okay well uh I'm sorry to
be a one-trick pony but yeah
takes takes Rook G3 yeah
and now do we play Bishop H5 or Rook C6
let's just I don't know Rook C6 I you
did kick me Bishop C3 I guess
ah you don't have D4 now so Bishop C3
might actually be quite good for uh for
a white
Bishop C3 now rookie E1 is also coming I
think you want to go Rook C4
and by the way we do have a result
between Lavon and Lanier I suspect that
was a repetition and to draw as expected
and what is going on Christian with the
game of of Hikaru I mean we thought
Carol is Boston
yes absolutely
he doesn't have any moves and Shanklin
is just pushing on the king side opening
up against uh the white structure on the
king side getting ready to open up the
king G4 is coming there's no way to stop
it and once the age file opens up I'm
going to have another Avenue for my
attack this is just not looking great at
all not only that but after G5 this
bishop will get the job as well I'm
going to go to G5 creating uh havoc on
the h-61
thread there's also an immediate threat
if y does nothing here we can play H4
and then Rook takes E4 because
I have to defend the Rook with Rook to
D2 the problem is this is exactly what's
happening you're adding another Target
on this h6c1 diagram I go G4 Bishop to
G5 to follow up it's just it's just
horrible it's over it's just it's over
at this point this is this is the moment
in our broadcast where we say if there
are children watching please they have
to leave the room I mean this is
terrible what uh what on Earth did
Hikaru do this is
but we do have a move let me catch up
with the players we do have Knight D2 on
the board no he's still he's still sorry
straight away so yeah you you don't just
refresh choices no no no yeah our entire
line is on the board in the uh line all
the way up to Rook A1 and Jan is now
thinking
you know
Christian was suggesting Rook C4 oh no
this page five yes it was the question
of how do I defend uh the G6 bond with
and Bishop obviously H5 keeping stuff
covered and by the way intimating me
before yeah maybe on a very very good
day for sure so the problem with Rook to
C4 is that after Bishop to C3 uh very
often the line that we were looking at
um with the bishop on E2 yes yes so if
you do try to go Rook to C4 yeah and
look for immediate counter play via the
d-pawn after Bishop takes B4 yeah
problem is that both of my roofs are
going to create some matching thread
actually okay seven okay seven Rook G8
is exactly yeah that that that hurt that
hurt uh which is why Bishop H5 was makes
a lot of sense
has already played Rook G3 which is Rook
David three I wonder if after
bishopituki wants to go to ah3 and I
also wonder if it improves anything
because you can I think you can play
with page five reasonably happily even
in that position if you wanted to uh to
keep no big difference between the rook
and H3 and also I'm wondering if why
can't exactly yeah King c6b5 be a little
bit more active oh Bishop E2 I mean yeah
for sure Yana is saying look if you let
me out of here with the draw I'll I'll
be very very grateful but for a moment
there I'm I'm sitting there saying
hello uh Peter King C6 King B5 I think
what probably you're a little active
yeah I was going to say white eventually
plays b2b3 but if white plays b2b3 how
are we ever challenging the bishop on
before exactly that'll keep the eighth
week okay Rook E3 played after Bishop no
King C6
with Bishop E2 Rook E3 Rook E3
by the way guys yeah it feels like mvl
is making a lot of progress in his game
against people I might actually have a
winning position right now whoa whoa
whoa we were expecting that game to
finish in a draw very soon exactly
that's not what's happening right now
okay let me just bring that was the
Berlin with four Rooks but wait a minute
the king got a king
E4 he's about two active I saw a king on
E6 kind of blockading an E5 Bond a while
back
um
has he walked into some mating Nets uh
Peter what's here what's your take not
just here but the king will continue
continuously uh get you know bumped
around the jerks are going to be very
annoying from like for if you get a
check from C4 you don't know whether to
go forward or back it could also maybe
make an argument for starting with Rook
F3 so that actually doesn't go forward
yeah right
um
you still have weaknesses and your king
is quite unsafe it's not going to get
boy have they played head to head in
Rapid look at that I'm kind of stunned
that MBL has such a dominant score there
Peter 24 21 wins pardon me to 11 losses
yeah he appears to be a new you know
enjoying uh this this particular
heads up much more than his opponent for
sure yeah exactly exactly and you can
also see that he's building a very nice
time advantage on the clock right now
five minutes only for Fabiano in a very
difficult position the problem is that I
have so many targets right now the pawn
on H4 is a target upon on F7 is a Target
and your king is a Target that is the
big problem and I will be able to set up
my Rooks potentially after to G5
followed by root to G4 and then Rook to
F4 and now at some point I'm going to
pick up one of your weaknesses either H4
or F7 very very difficult position uh
for Favi to defend indeed
Hikaru Sam Shanklin okay Rook D2 and as
you uh as a prescribed G4 and Bishop G5
definitely on Sam's uh agenda anything
else just I mean it just feels like
White's positions so
uh terrible that uh well just simply
Queen to D6 is an option as well exactly
continue targeting the D3 part
that if we can just take that pawn there
are so many uh tactics in the position
for example Queen to D6 you might see
Knight to E2 and say that okay you're
getting some sort of compensation I have
Bishop takes E4 right now
Bishop takes E4
nothing moves yeah I think that the
choice for Sam here is quite simply
whether he wants to switch to giving
mate on the king side starting with G5
G4 which looks frankly very very logical
exactly very tempting yeah or if you if
you want to start picking up Bear Down
on the D3 Pawn Yeah and white is so far
from creating any sort of counter
chances like you can go Rook to C2 yeah
G4 of course
G4 of course yeah HG it takes G4 I
wonder why not Queen takes I guess
Knight H2 Knight F3 was uh something he
did not have to allow with Tempe
well spotted Knight H2 is a nice Tempo
move HG came quickly Rook C2 is a kind
of a strange choice because we can just
take on D3 you know
well you are attacking the pawn on c7s
well not really because it's a Tempo
against the queen queen is sort of a
yeah like what is this
like what is it and Sam says well I can
also now capture with the knight uh
targeting the bishop on uh F2
very very dominant position yes Queen C1
I guess is the plan but I mean black is
a blown up and continues having
you know by far the better position as
well generated one threat yeah Bishop D6
followed by Queen B3 or queen D7
followed by something well 1963 in fact
yeah I quite like 1983 as well Rook D1
on tab two there uh everything
everything the wheels have fallen off
here for Hikaru I don't know what has
happened to us this is a very poor game
very very uncharacteristic game by
Hikaru he is exactly clearly
something the first two days you'd never
really found his rhythm but this game in
particular just oh terrible let's uh
avert our eyes and again jump back to
the uh there also has made significant
progress and I was wondering uh uh a
little bit and
Jan appears to have missed a very
concrete idea to perhaps even straight
up equalize but it was difficult to find
and I think I I can sort of understand
why it hasn't been played after rookie
three I think it's impossible really to
play like this the engine suggests you
can play Rook D2 here Rook David too
okay with the idea of Bishop Bishop C3
Bishop takes C3 and I guess the plan is
beta xc3 Rook D1 check
whoa generating a passer on the a file
putting my Bishop on D3 and saying yeah
okay I am going to have so much exchange
that's worth an exchange uh this is this
I guess is the uh the plan here but I I
think it's very very difficult to
voluntarily uh start trading pieces like
this and he just continues shuffling but
now the white Rook is if we go back to
uh yeah rookie 8 Rook B8 uh White is now
a lot of a lot more active then but how
do you make any more progress right now
B6 and G5 Rook to G6 but what if I just
simply keep pushing
G4
um you know it's interesting that he
played Rook B6 he could have played Rook
G8 and uh exactly G5 wouldn't have been
possible then you have to go [ __ ] page
five and that makes your Bishop passive
exactly uh I was really really hoping uh
to as as black to establish my Bishop on
e4 uh and you will and if he gets that
then yeah then he is back to being kind
of completely occasionally exactly
pretty much yeah exactly and look at the
time difference on the clock nine
minutes for Nepal he's been blitzing out
his last few moves and only three
minutes and 50 seconds for Ali Raza
squishy bottom time getting a little
nervous here yeah it's a it's one of
those positions where you feel like you
should be much better but it's it's so
Elusive and the making progress is so
difficult that yeah we're watching a
very very strong player and I think
alireza in general is a very good very
strong technical player which is not
always the case with 19 year olds but
true that
um
grabbing the bull by the horns Peter
Bishop C3 just you know this bishop on
B4 I can't stand it anymore I don't
understand five here might not be
playable is it Bishop C5 or K5 yeah I
thought I had some threads but I don't
maybe maybe I do yeah you don't have a
good check yeah I have threats crazily
enough I mean oops g3's Got rugby G5
okay
maybe actually even towards that one
yeah although yeah I mean it's but let's
go Bishop D6 guys yeah
we were missing you cannot go G3 because
of Bishop F3 yeah sorry help me out yeah
all the way Bishop C6 through K5 instead
of taking on F2 after Rook C1 King H2
you go Bishop D6 track
go forward
or K5 Rook C1 King H2 Bishop D6 now
don't take Bishop D6 check yeah well
it's been just wins The Exchange back
yeah let's do finish with three of
courses no problem
yes it is yeah why they're still I'm
guessing you know somewhat better have
to take stakes in King G3 but obviously
what we had wanted to do but uh you
removed Bishop D6 respects Christian
very nice very very nice forcing white
to give back the exchange so Bishop C3
uh leads as nowhere uh suggestions for
uh I'll erase a p Peter it's just very
difficult because you know you you
forced the pawn on G6 which was kind of
vulnerable you forced it forward now the
weakness arguably is on F5 but as you
were pointing out Bishop d3bish before
is a very logical thing to uh to aim for
so let's go through them the clock is
ticking down one minute and 30 seconds
for us he's burned half of his remaining
time on this move he's he's recognizing
things have gone South sorry uh and by
the way you might actually lose this
position some
if you get too low on time and you make
one mistake you might yeah absolutely
yeah at some point it might become
double-edged for sure if the d-pawn
starts running
you don't want to see it yeah
three and now Bishop C5 I assume is uh
of course well
for force is maybe strong but you
you would very much like to keep the the
bishop alive the the dark Square Bishop
for black so if you take on C3 the
problem can I put my Grandmaster title
of her grabs Rook takes C3
by the way came very quickly I was just
about to proposal
and this is what I'm talking about yeah
this is heading into is running yeah
this is getting into risky territory
yeah
4g3 even Bishop even though I'm guessing
is playable but I would very much like
to maybe try to uh put the question to
White suddenly default B4 is strong
though I think maybe for before shifting
of Shifting arbishop away from it does
seem like you also have some funny moves
after D4 Bishop to B4 for example Bishop
before using once again the the line
mate ideas yes
D4 is not Forest though we let's let's
go back for a second and and look at
Alternatives because we can we can
attack the F to pawn forcing Bishop B1
or we can pick up the pawn on B2 or we
can just simply take on B2 and say okay
this trade really doesn't favor you as
much as you think it does young man
please continue right right I mean
you've mentioned a moment ago when a B5
B4 was played by Yan you're trying to
play a four versus three well let's
trade the a pawn for the B Pawn
and uh by the way just again maybe we're
being too optimistic for Yan here for a
moment but if I did play F4 and G3 is
that completely bizarrely no Bishop B6
yeah maybe specifically apologies yeah
maybe actually maybe this is why you
take on B2 just to take away those ideas
of Bishop before and Bishop B6 to
control those squares because I very
much got myself excited about the
opportunity of playing for G3 and again
uh Christian help us out on the clock
times uh one minute 23 seconds for Ali
Reza 7 minutes and 30 seconds for nepo
getting getting nervy no absolutely I
mean with those Bishops swarming around
your king like this right and that deep
on if you let it one tempo go to D3 D4
D3 you just take some bit too yeah it's
a very very solid practical decision and
by the way good things also comes with
the idea of Bishop D3 so that we are
very very quickly uh it's important not
to blunder the bishop before I guess as
Christian keeps on reminding us
uh what do you mean
I mean automatically you play roxy2 here
if you if you don't think about him
who's very much Bishop before maybe and
if I take a check which one
and I drop my rook in the way but how
would you say no no but then I pick up
both of you I win all of you oh you win
both missions
Rick takes C7 and Bishop takes E7 I was
one I chose yanchos B3 creating a thread
of G4 G3 as well and Bishop B5 is a very
logical continuation by Larissa another
big question is can we play G4 do we get
mated if we play G4 because I won that
pawn on D3 of course oh that's the dream
anchor anchors away but it's you know
maybe we do get amazing it's a bit it's
a bit touch and go I'm not sure I uh so
let's go to K5
yeah I'm very very uh uncertain about it
I'm about this I know what you wanted to
do with anchoring the bishop but somehow
somehow by the way guys
Fabiano uh repeat a Christian uh you
said that
he just won his game against me
was in the chasing pack yeah absolutely
not only in the chasing pack he's
actually the leader until that game
between Ali Raza and Nepal finishes
exactly nine points one point ahead of
alireza exactly yeah and uh Sam in the
meantime is three pawns up with two
Bishops against two knights I'm not
entirely sure why this game is still on
um okay but Bishop E5 uh pause here for
a second because uh this is a very
important moment I mean he I I don't
know if he's thinking I can save the
game I should be playing even harder he
did drop back with his Bishop Bishop to
C4 I think we should go to hikaru's game
just because I think we're going to see
a resignation very soon alrighty yeah
this is just yeah he clearly doesn't
like resigning and never has liked
resigning but the positions three bonds
and the Bishops Bishop
E7 and Bishop C5
if you leave the bishop on d8 here on
Prius
you might still make a draw which is a
kind of a said in that way Rook D4 is a
very easy yeah that's just
Hikaru is just in Blitz mode I will
never have given up one of the bishop
there there I I would like to launch a
formal complaint oh no we just played
five in a loud Rook takes B6 okay guys
Sam Sam rugby five is coming you're
losing another one oh my gosh what Sam
please please don't do this to us I know
where did A5 come from oh my good three
up and there are no threads
I mean it's legitimately a bit tricky
because your stuff starts hanging like
92 maybe 92 okay four
okay G3 I've won the E5 Pawn
yeah
oh no oh no Sam let's go let's let's not
uh wait wait the the howls will be heard
all down
hang on GF and then Knight C3 check or
something and we might lose but okay I
think after Rook to B5 I have to give up
another pawn and just go A4
well why is Hikaru thinking I mean yeah
Sam has already done one wobble and Rook
B5 and just keep the pressure on let's
go F4 no A4 sorry
A4 Rook Rook B5 A4 Rook takes E5 rookie
five Bishop F4 right gotcha
but I do have a check you do have a
check on E7 yes King d8 and Knight to
five honestly I mean if we play King B6
on this version we're probably winning
but yes you are likely so
oh but yeah this is this is just so
completely unnecessary so so you asked
me to move to the game because we
expected Hikaru to resign and no we did
get a resignation instead
and what happened with farrugia and uh I
think I think they're repeated yeah wow
what a remarkable yeah this is a
miraculous Escape there by Jan
considering uh
uh yeah he just couldn't find any way to
progress and uh I guess he was also
running incredibly short on time so he
just repeated there exactly that is wow
what a save a huge uh swing in that game
so do you keep the bishop right now or
do you take on it yeah going back to
hikaru's game which is
terribly amusing hey fortnite he
currently chose not to take only five he
I think he's correctly estimating The
Rook endings here provide him with more
cover so to speak
so let's go Bishop B6 in that case uh
one sec uh can we take and go King D6
okay five Rook F4 that was sort of my
so Rook to B4 no he's gone he's gone
Bishop D4 instead he said I don't want
uh he says I'm okay with the Rook ending
but I would like to slightly different
information to my terms yeah
and chocolate has beaten uh Jeffrey Sean
which is a very very big win at the
tournament welcome back Shaq and
Jeffrey's first loss
and Jeffrey's first loss
we we had a show in America Welcome Back
Cotter
and uh there was a uh yeah
Kaplan correct who some of us know for
his poker other exploits yes your course
poker
so perhaps sikaru was so lost that even
after winning two points
an interesting Intermezzo what do you
like very fancy yeah very nice by Sam
there
king of Tui D Rook B4 I don't like this
why was this in Japan so I don't like
this but I kind of like the King on E2
so I had D3 check let's take with the
root guys take with the Rook I agree
yeah I think we should yeah and then
after Rook takes yeah this one actually
is kind of safely winning I would assume
because you never get to the G4 Pawn
Yeah so you go King E3 right yeah Rook
B4 I think you start pushing yeah this
is this is the way to do it yeah you'll
never take with the pawn here I'm pretty
sure you your main priority here has to
be preserving the the passer on the A5
but how easy is this yeah yeah let's
keep going I think it's
fairly straightforward p8 can be five
King B5 and you want to hide on B yeah
um yeah this should be
there should be a reasonably
straightforward but
sometimes when I'm watching Sam at the
board I get nervous even
I'm a I'm a hundred feet away from her I
mean he makes me nervous do you pick up
the nerves of your opponent when they do
that little shaking and wobbling beater
yeah it does a little bit it's it
transmits a little bit but on the other
hand like you you like him nervous if
you're a concussion that's right because
you know five minutes ago he had three
extra pawns that's the Bishops against
tonight so like this is an unthinkable
amount of progress right and Waltzing is
way too
simple Victory and King E3 before yeah
you have to play rookie eight you have
to have at least some reply to A3 A2
exactly otherwise you just resign so you
have to play rookie eight
yep I like King B5 once again if the
king gets to B3 the game probably five
King D3 probably yeah and then I think
we go rugby three Rook G3 I think what
wins is Ruby 303 unfortunately for
Hikaru and I can combine protecting the
a pawn with winning the pawn on G2 and
then I will eventually just switch to
promoting the Jeep
makes sense uh but yeah so let's keep
going King D3 King D3 because I think
we're going to see that yeah it's
probably it's probably going to happen
D4 I guess yeah
but yeah but now I I got I share them I
don't I don't even go over G3 yet I go
King before I I make sure my Kings you
want to hide in front of the pawn and
then I will put Uchi three later exactly
I think this is the yeah somewhere
around here you start realizing your
your causes
probably lost that's why but so close
yeah yeah but the fact that he gets so
close in this game is just absolutely
Christian no singing
we'll pay you not to sing
I'll take a collection that's hard
production is already reaching into the
wallet I promise you guys there's no
singing happening
we've had enough parties and uh in the
Central West End
someone made a role as someone who has
been you know disallowed to sing in his
life I I I commiserate greatly with with
Christians
situations emotions right now exactly
all right and by the way I believe those
are all the results instead of our
normal diet of one Victory per round
there's probably going to be three yeah
this will be the bloodiest round that
we've had so far in this event exactly
and yeah so far coming back to that so
far we've had 8 out of 30 which is a
little bit more than a quarter of the
games okay so okay as expected the only
move you could make and by the way this
is if Sam wins so yeah if someone wins
let's not call this one just yet yeah
it's close enough to call though
seriously uh it just feels like you just
play all of these very natural looking
moves if he plays King B5 I think he
wins if he doesn't play King B5 he
chooses something else here uh I think
we might still have uh more more things
to watch but yeah King B5 and I do feel
that Sam's strength is actually his end
game yes that's one of you I very
strongly felt feel the same that we're
in technical positions he does play them
very very well
that's one thing whenever he made a jump
from like 2550 to 2700 this is one thing
that he focused on Rook endgame
specifically yeah I think I think the
work he's done over the years with uh
Jacob is paid off he's definitely you
know
something that should send them in good
Stead
uh when playing positions like this
do you have a particular trainer Peter
that you
tip your hat and say thank you very much
for all of the efforts well as you've
done in my like in my life yes I
definitely uh you know I went from I had
a sort of a childhood coach that's
raised me from seven years until like
maybe 12 or 13 and then we parted ways
and then at the age of around 16 ish 17
maybe I got picked up by uh by the man
who I think is absolutely instrumental
in everything that happened to me after
the international master from Leningrad
called Andrea looking
yeah who is not very well known in the
west but uh yeah I could I could tell
you some story so like Lucan was like
Furman was the teacher
I'm not going to compare myself to
carpool yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
yeah I mean he I probably would have
made it as some kind of a chess player
in general but I think without him it
would have been way way harder and right
would have had much less guaranteed
results so yeah I'm eternally grateful
to to Andrei hilovich for everything
everything he's done for me it was a
incredibly incredibly and is he written
any works that you might recommend no he
is not uh he's not a writing coach here
but he he brought up generations of
Leningrad and Saint Petersburg
youngsters like he worked with Sakaya
before me and then after after me he
worked curly Alexander is another
another of his pupils he's a really
outstanding names I mean excuse me it
was actually kind of it was a very nice
kind of a feeling of passing of the
Baton when right because when I started
helping kiril for the candidates it was
a kind of a you know the looking family
you know for working together
generations and generations of uh
looking pupils helping each other so it
was a very very nice by the way I think
we have A3 A3 A3 is still fine because
he wants to play rookie Rook A4 and in
general just wants to play put the Rook
on A4 and that obviously wins pretty
much every every time exactly if you get
the Rook behind the game the game just
ends
Brooks behind cash pawns yeah
um okay do sorry one more okay four King
B3
or you think A2 dominates or just twins
no yeah I'm sorry I was going to drive
your Rook away from you pardon me as
right yeah well I'm very good you're yes
I understand
if you start with rooked way it looked
away for any take on A4 and you say that
after that King to C3 is coming I still
have one Temple
I have G3 which but I mean even A2 is
winning honestly it's not the only way
yes A2 is probably weird as well yeah
and anything is winning like just
starting we just start running towards
the king side it's uh yeah yeah the fact
that the Jeep ones are still on the
board obviously is improving many of our
enemies greatly because we can offer The
Rook trade pretty much at any point in
the game yeah Hikaru is correctly
burning for his time trying to figure
out if there is some kind of a miracle
he can produce but doesn't doesn't feel
like it he's gonna he's given a check
from E5 King to A4 yeah but now after
King A4 A2 is just a kind of a finishing
threat King situ yeah we go
rookie eight he wants yeah but then King
A3 still wins on the spot right it
doesn't really matter a one a one night
check is also winning but we're never
doing that you're right yeah we just do
we just do either King A3 or Rook B5 for
K5 and
is just but King A3 I have rookie three
check ah okay okay then we go Ruby five
for K5 yeah okay fair enough
wait a second so rugby five I go rookie
four check yeah that's actually trickier
trickier than we thought right okay
there's some kind of a study where we're
on it it's it's winning it's it's weird
but then eventually rookie one will
happen I mean the thing yeah exactly I
was going to say like if if we can't
calculate the South though we should go
takes G2 and we're in that position okay
just take on G2 here like we this this
one is not going to be fake
that was actually pretty funny yeah
Trotsky uh study
yeah and now the big trick of course is
not to blunder into some kind of a
stalemate
yeah just we I think we actually just
give up the a pawn and and we win the
Jeep one yeah just
G2 no there are two tricks here because
yeah you play rookie three and now the
the Temptation has to be to go Ruby to
check and then A2 and then Rook takes A3
and we start the Desperado Rook there
yeah and uh this one probably is best
avoided we start crying at that yeah I
mean it might not be a draw but we we
definitely do not want that no
it's just a race to the king side now
King C4 Rook a three King D4 and just
yeah that should probably win
B3 maybe was the cleanest yeah but yeah
what Sam is doing is very good yes
especially chasing the king to the
a-files that is very clean yeah yeah to
keep the king even
one for the file also we have space for
your own King yeah yeah this is very
clean
but again
it's kind of off-putting I mean he's
he's two pawns up and he's completely
winning and he's he's shaking like you
know I don't I don't believe what I'm
doing is good but I mean
the shock to the system that a sequence
of moves A5 Roots producers you know
yeah it's true true it really does it
really takes sometimes sometimes
honestly I mean his position continued
being completely winning but still Kudos
kudos to him for not really you know
collapsing under the string because like
you see the move Rook takes B6 appear on
the board in front of you it's now G2
wins yeah G2 wins anything wins yeah G2
wins on the spot actually uh just ends
the game followed by Rook to A1 yeah
okay one and yeah and we kind of resign
yeah
there we go
Sam had a very very brief smile like
thank goodness that is over by the way
for Sam Shanklin uh also six draws plus
one day plus one though yeah feeling
good uh
we have a down down verot I I could
never pronounce that word yeah
again MBL mvl and others are leading so
it's uh
whatever I mean I'm giving up on my on
my you know attempts
there's a French uh word there that that
that's gone missing in our repertoire
help him out Christianity
so it's a situation where there are two
rulers two rulers okay a duopoly wapally
yes okay I like it I like it
yes and uh on on the topic of uh two
rulers yes very smooth Segway now we are
going to offer you sure for you some uh
some merge to take a look at and we
start with I believe this very very nice
looking uh uh cotton polyester blend zip
up jacket with pockets with pockets very
important you can never have enough
Pockets exactly pictures the same place
St Louis rapid and Blitz logo on the
front and the uh St Louis chess club
logo on the back and is available as is
everything we are showing you during
this commercial in breaks on
cubicstl.com very very nice and
understanding the standings yeah as you
can see there uh the two the two
Frenchmen uh on top there on nine out of
14 uh Jan and Sam now are the uh the
chasing pack right two people on 50 are
Lanier and Jeffrey after the first loss
of the tournament goes back to 50 and 5B
is still on -1 level steel and minus one
and shark with a victory actually
catches up to Hikaru who goes back to -2
this is like wow very very unusual that
that second half of the field has some
really fabulous names we're gonna take a
break and we're gonna be back with
around eight of three rounds of Rapid
see on the other side of the break stay
tuned
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hey St Louis the Ascension Charity
Classic presented by Emerson is back
this September don't miss the excitement
when the PGA toured Champions best
compete again all for charity September
9th through the 11th at Norwood Hills
Country Club Pro-Am spots Hospitality
packages VIP tickets and more available
now at Ascension charityclassic.com
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the
continuation of day three of Saint Louis
rapid and Blitz and these are your
standings after the first round today
with a Maxima sheragrav joining the lead
uh tied for his countrymen with his
temperament alireza firoja on nine out
of uh 14.
the Frenchman with five names
and Nepal and Sam Shanklin uh joining a
pack a one point behind is Sam Shanklin
took down uh his colleague rifle and
Carlo Nakamura wow a very eventful round
but first let's jump uh to our colleague
Anastasia who caught up with mvl
foreign
[Music]
and game and I thought this position is
obviously slightly better but I should
be defensible I thought H4 from Fabi was
not great because then
um the difference is my Rook is on
network so ready to jump to D4 or maybe
to the queen side great Witnesses so
smart active than on F5 and then I had
many plans I finally sacrificed this one
on E5 but then his King was Under Fire
always I got back the phone and then it
just my Rooks were always more active
than his works and did never had time to
create any sort of
of mating threats against making because
then he would lose upon on each Force so
then it was just a matter of technique I
guess
this skill wasn't danger it felt like
why do you think he went for this land
or he didn't have anything better at
this moment at this moment she already
don't have anything better because if he
doesn't take only five he goes King E7
then I go hook C4 B6 B4 and I assume
much better so
um because then I'm crushing on on the
queen side
properties are still some chances to
defend I'm not really sure but in any
case I would have been considerably
better
preparation against
a Jeffrey
so it should be eight was it all from
preparation actually no because uh
instead of 4b8 Bishop E5 turns out to be
stronger and I remembered some vibes
of things but I couldn't remember the
good line
while everyone was playing in the
Olympia with most of the players what
did you do I was chilling mostly
um
I actually think I took some vacations
I don't even remember where but uh
like I know it was mostly in Paris just
getting some rest uh
oh yeah yeah I went to south of France
and got a few a few days of uh of chill
and you know
uh just
um you know we we powering and you know
being ready and digital to fight here
yeah
feel fresh after all this time
yes also because I I arrived early also
in the US I went to Miami visited some
friends of mine I did some good friends
there went to New York afterwards so you
know feels like I'm almost feeling at
home
[Music]
and Maxine continues to bedevil
with that Victory uh had a very dominant
record in their head-to-head matchup and
MBL uh
um absolutely and the appearance for
round eight our leaders are as you as
you see as you saw there on your screen
MBL is plugged against senior Dominguez
and alireza is white again for the
second round in a row he's playing
against
who's not having a particular Stellar
tournament so far but as usual plenty of
plenty of things to uh to look forward
to in this round of the tournament and
surprisingly enough the Napo versus
Shanklin match very very key matchup of
those two players who are type third
we'll jump right into the games as
they've begun alireza is with white
against Lavon aronian and Levon has just
played this Berlin but then came D3
Bishop C5 and quickly the players have
achieved this position this time with A7
A6 yeah but it's now it's now looking uh
despite the G3 C3 anti Berlin being
played initially this is now sort of
back to that territory that we even
briefly discussed during one of the
previous shows where I mentioned that
alireza seems to be one of the people
who enjoys very much this new reasonably
new plan of putting the bishop on H4 and
then G3 and trying to create pressure in
the center by pushing the 3d4 bishop B7
is an interesting Movement by by Levon
can you get away with that well I think
the idea is just to go back to the six
it's a bit curious that he chooses to
spend a full Tempo on this but I guess
Bishop he said the Stutter Step yeah
okay sorry but I guess the argument is
that making sure that white is no longer
pinning on iPhone F6 is is good enough
for us so we don't have to worry about
things too much if I if I can speak for
Ali Reza for a moment and be
persistently putting pressure on type on
92 I wonder if I can play Knight H5 I'm
not entirely sure but if if I can I
would very much like to of course it's a
useful it's a useful Square for my for
my pieces here with black and Bishop H4
I think I would like to play F6 I would
like to play F6 and claim that I'm
prepared to play Knight F4 next move
okay uh it's all it's all uh kind of
unclear but we have more exciting games
in the rounds so let's take a look at
some other positions uh well let's jump
to the game of Napo versus Sam Shanklin
because again it's become a key matchup
thanks to Sam's victory in the last
round and b2b3 that is a surprising move
for me exactly at the moment when you're
on when you've already played Bishop D2
you're going to play B3 well I think I
assume the point is very simply that we
would like to play Knight C3 and E2 E4
and we don't want one in a Gambit
fashion so we're protecting the pawn on
C4 preparing for Knight C3 that would be
all Bishop c3903 as you're indicating
both of those plans are reasonably well
known okay okay well and yeah well
interestingly uh Jan I think has
basically nailed his colors to the Mast
right now as a very very prominent new
player on the Catalan scene and he
appears to be getting it in every game
like people are just very very happily
discussing the Catalan with him like
seemingly in every single white game he
has in this tournament he played two
catalans yesterday right and his first
wide game today is once again a Catalan
so yeah 93 not Bishop C3 in the end I'm
kind of jealous of these people like
Vladimir kramnik who found the Catalan
very early in life and just never left
it it just became a lifelong favorite
and uh Christian had joined the
conversation what's called your eye in
this round eight opening there was a big
theoretical battle going on in this game
of Fabiano against
this position after Knight to G4 Rook 2
E2 has been seen before Knight to F6
even going just backwards like that is
one of the moves but I was looking at
King to h8 this makes a lot of sense you
want to go F5 you just played the move
Knight to G4 open DF file and now you
want to follow it up with F5 also you
haven't committed this d-pawn to D6 yet
so in case these two pawns get exchanged
D5 is going to come in one move with
tremendous consequences so this was a
very interesting uh position H3 F5 you
don't want to take on G4 because if you
do take on G4 after taking on G4 opening
up the f file Queen to H4 is coming
taking advantage of the fact that this
bishop on C5 creates such an unpleasant
pin on this A7 G1 diagonal this gives
black the advantage so after F5 Bishop
to G5 would have been the best move in
the position and quite an intriguing
position would have ensued now he
decided against that after Rook to E2 he
played the move Knight to D4 another one
of the options in this line what I don't
like is that after Knight takes D4 he
decided to take with the E Pawn and
closed down the action of the bishopone
C5 I don't like that now at this point
Fabiano had this option of potentially
just playing the move H3 which I'm not
100 sure why he didn't this is the first
time he spent some time on his move he
had 26 minutes at this point he played
the move Bishop to F4 which I don't
think is the correct way to approach
this position H3 was the right move of
course Knight to F6 I can just simply
pin that Knight you don't want to be as
passive in this position your structure
is already damaged as black after taking
on D4 and doubling up the pawns you want
to play active the problem is after
Knight to E5 Bishop to B3 now F4 is
coming with Tempo this seems to be
giving white a tremendous Advantage F4
is coming followed by F5 the bishop goes
out and then Knight to D to finish my
development and I'm going to enjoy a
trauma and this attack due to my space
advantage on the king side he did not do
that he played the move Bishop to F4 D6
this is the current position we have on
the board by the way Mama they are with
25 minutes and 51 seconds he hasn't
spent a single seconds so far but it
does seem like maybe he just simply
missed that move H3 Bishop to F4 D6 now
after H3 the problem is not only that I
have Knight to E5 I also have this idea
of Queen to F6 potentially and then
getting the Knight to E5 everything
seems to be coming down with Tempo and
you will not enjoy that move F4 as
easily in the position I see this
position and I feel black might have
just simply equalized out of the opening
thank you for that very much uh looking
at the Jeffrey Zhang game and somehow a
spy is smiling to myself Peter because
Hikaru is having such a bad tournament
he said yeah you never mind let's throw
in the kitchen thing yeah but before we
discuss this yeah there's a very very
exciting game in progress between uh
linear Dominguez and mvl yeah I feel
that they're actually repeating the game
that I think uh linear won the best game
of the tournament prize
get uh too complicated for me but I I
have a feeling this is still that game
right and it's interesting that they're
both repeating clearly mvl has uh if I'm
correct and then steal that yeah yeah it
is still that game actually right uh and
will clearly has figured out how to uh
equalize that he he complained uh about
that loss that he had just that
temporary
loss of uh the the opening uh uh and he
blundered the game away in one move so
uh clearly had it in his opening file he
just missed the the moment and you're
right it went very very very quickly uh
H5 played here by biliniere this is a
kind of a position where we we kind of
have to make an executive decision
somewhere around about now whether we
want to try and figure out what's going
on here or we just let them play they
know the theory yeah and return to it
when something really dramatic happens
or perhaps Christian can can explain to
US
state of theory is and well it's very
strange that he played this move H5
because this does seem to allow black to
just equalize after the move D5 now the
game that they played previously was
after Bishop to C2 instead of H5 Bishop
to C2 and now Queen to D7 was played in
that game now it does seem I was going
through the lines it does seem that
white gets an advantage at least there
very pleasant end game in this position
Queen to E6 was played H takes if you do
take on G6 after Queen takes F4 this
seems to be giving white a tremendous
attack on the king side you have to
exchange instead of that but do you
really want to uh play this end game and
just try to survive the same game as
black it doesn't look good you have so
many weaknesses the pawn on D6 the pawn
on A6 because I will be getting with
that Rook to A7 I have a lot of Targets
in the position and a beautiful Central
Bishop only for a not so safe King in
the center I really don't like the
situation for black mvl was not curious
about repeating this one and trying to
see what Lanier came uh with his
preparation instead of that actually lay
in the year played this move H5 but
after D5 what's happening in the
position you have to take this bishop 27
I take on D3 I'm starting to have my own
play around your king queen to C2 is
coming Rook to ba potentially even D20
followed by Queen to C1 so you have to
be fast yeah the question is what
happens after HG Yes HD check
and now D2 right right other screen
takes H7 work
exactly this is just losing actually
yeah you cannot take on H7 because of
root to C1 you get checkmated so you
have to shy away uh from this attack on
the H5 with Rook to G1 but my position
is safe right now I can just simply go
back reinforce the threat of Rook to C1
force you to get passive with Rook to B1
and then blood clearly it just feels
like exactly black is winning right now
so wow that's so how do we make a draw
with white
let's see let's take a look take Queen
to C2 by the way black seems to be
better in this position the best move is
to go A3
wait for black to take and now King to
A2 wow once again you have to shy away
from for example if you go Queen F6 I
take on D1 and then Rook to C1 that's
the big problem right wow so you cannot
do that you cannot allow that this is
going to be a losing end game you have
to go King to A2 now this creates the
front of quick websites because Queen
takes D1 is not going to come with Tempo
you cannot take on D1 because Rook to C1
is not coming with a check so at this
point it does seem like perhaps Queen to
C4 King to a one or King to B1 and then
maybe a repetition is going to ensue
very very intriguing position
is linear aware of all these intricacies
right now well he he didn't have that
look for a moment there of the man who's
questioning his preparations
like what is this H5 did
it that's a bad sign your opponent gives
you a big nice big yawn in a very very
sharp position and you're thinking do
yourself
what has he prepared for me H5 a very
very sharp again uh we we got there but
then we didn't get there tell me about
your feelings of the Hikaru Nakamura I'm
just very happy yes I'm just very happy
this is happening because I've you know
Hikaru returning to his sort of
spiritual home and exactly playing the
king's Indian again is just good good uh
I would like to you know wait until
something uh sort of crystallizes on the
board though because my understanding of
the king's Indian I mean
rudimentary I think is a is a kind of a
generous way of describing it so uh I
don't know Peter yeah somebody who wins
the Russian Championship eight times by
playing zero kings
that was maybe helpful okay yeah I think
I played Samuel in the very very early
ones okay in the like mid to late 90s so
we'll let this percolate and brew a bit
uh let's jump back to the farugia versus
uh yeah we're actually uh appeared to
have gotten to the position we were
discussing he played Bishop g369 B2
might be two Knight H5 is Page four and
livon is choosing between F6 and Bishop
B7 I assume 27 looks awkward but Bishop
7 looks playable uh I would like to play
F6 if I could yes as I mentioned I would
very much like to have my my knight on
the floor eventually it looks a little
strange there but there doesn't seem to
be any way of taking advantage of uh the
yeah I couldn't find hanging night I
didn't find any any useful way for white
to to exploit those options the very
desirable Knight takes E5 runs a Cropper
before after Rook takes okay let's just
go down because maybe actually continue
to continue the line here a little bit
really early I thought this was
completely unplayable but now I look at
this but maybe it's not yeah
pay for exactly oh D2 is hanging I know
but I'm planning to play Knight C4 and
play my reading a full Rook yeah very
good knight C4 I'm yeah I'm I'm planning
to claim I'm winning a full rukong bizu
here and H5 is still hanging H5 indeed
this is quite interesting yeah in the
meantime uh mvl did play g65 so uh I
don't know but I I think we kind of
confused ourselves here a little bit I
mean I was about to say that Knight
takes E5 was unplayable for this and
this uh seven actually is the choice by
um Biology one I said it looks awkward
but Levon clearly disagrees and uh said
that's perfectly fine I I
again after Bishop H4 Queen D7 on the
board and no F7 F6 no uh things for you
and Knight to C4 Knight C4 is logical G3
D4 is also something you could consider
doing without Knight C4 even just to try
to challenge the black center straight
away well I'm here and no I was about to
say am I ready for Knight F4 no Lavon
said let me play Queen G4 first
kind of keeping sort of that D3 D4
you're keeping an eye on that generally
I think he he I think is claiming that
G6 would be a good Square for the for
this piece eventually which I think is
true especially if you force me back
h2h3 Queen G6 somehow that Queen has
teleported from D to G6 you don't
oftentimes see it there in these
positions but it looks quite okay and
Christian uh Jump Right In what has
caught uh your eye in this round eight I
was once again trying to catch up with
this game between Fabiano and Shakir and
after a4a5 what's happened happened on
the board King to h8 obviously uh
signaling the fact that black wants to
go F5 and open up the f file Knight to
D2 Queen to F6 Bishop to G3 this was the
critical moment in the position Queen to
F6 a bit of a dubious move now the idea
is clear after Bishop to G3 which was
not a great move in the position G5 came
on the board and now now what black is
striving to achieve is a bind on the
dark Source followed by Knight to G6
Knight to F4 and not allow white to get
that move F4 in the position now if only
after Queen to F6 white would have
played the move Bishop to H2 after G5 F4
take on F4 the [ __ ] Pawn G3 is not
under attack and after Rook to F2 I'm
later on going to Simply pick up the F4
Pawn open up the f file your king is not
very safe in the position and that gives
white a tremendous Advantage with the
bishopon G3 unfortunately does that
doesn't work after taking Rook to F do I
have this move Bishop takes H3 if you do
take on H3 after root 2 G8 we take
advantage of the fact that the bishop
remains pinned on G3 which actually just
finishes the game this is completely
winning for black and if you do take
after Bishop takes H3 Rook takes F4 I go
Queen to G7 attacking targeting the
[ __ ] Pawn G3 you don't have enough time
to take on H3 you don't have enough time
to to restore the material balance in
the position and blockages completely
winning now this is the problem after
Rook 2 E1 Rook to G8 it does seem like
black obtains that bind on the dark
squares and I don't see it for happening
anytime soon I feel shock rear has a
great position in this one thank you for
that Christian I just want to draw your
attention Peter if I can to this very
key matchup between Jan and Sam
shankland as this Catalan yeah once
again a very very nice bit of prep there
by Jan and a very pleasant position
straight out of the opening I wanted to
say doesn't this uh don't you find wise
position attractive here very much so in
fact I think it's a kind of a position
which could very easily just go
completely off the rails for black
exactly you do have some tactical
chances though after 96 as I now
realized you can play Rook C7 okay and I
want to play something like B3 before
here just to kind of further reinforce
the idea of the bishop 186 is in trouble
but I think Knight takes E5 might work
doable really maybe yeah 25 Rock cd7
although before before
this bishop Bishop C8 maybe it doesn't
work maybe it doesn't work
I like your Rook AC one very no I I
think uh there are issues there and uh
he's got a rook C5 and Rook C5 I thought
was just straight up unplayable due to
something by Queen A4
or before before five ideas I thought I
mean F4 would be a would be a kind of a
fallback position for us here for sure
we we have that we always have that in
our pocket just reinforcing the pawn on
E5 and then reintroducing all those
threats of this particular before if you
were looking for a tactical yeah I
wanted I wanted more I wanted to to see
if maybe we can finish the game straight
away I don't see how why not Bishop
takes Knight takes there's 35 in the end
there right Rook to xb5 here Bishop
c65 yeah this is the one I meant yeah
and in this position we we lose 35
unfortunately yeah
and do I have to take you have 26 here
but it feels artificial unconvinced yeah
I don't know I I actually I was thinking
Queen A4 yeah Queen D6 looks maybe
slightly more promising but
it's weird I don't know uh it may be
winning but it looks pretty good uh what
do you think Christian what's the
problem with Knight B8 in that variation
at the end uh at the end sorry with B4
yes B4 rookie five yes B5 I'm not sure
about B5 I think maybe bishop B7 is
winning
perhaps just focusing on The Rook on E5
and not allowing it to come back don't
give the Rook on E5 the square C5 so
just play a move such as Queen to C3 try
to go to C7 potentially one even yeah
this just looks this just looks horrible
the idea that The Rook on E5 is not
coming back into play anytime soon ah
looks very very promising uh for Yan
here as we do have Knight D6 Rook C4
Rook C5 yeah this is on the board and
Jan clearly I think Ian also realizes
that his position is very promising and
could potentially you know it's it's one
of those positions which might just have
a solution yes a very very forcing line
of play where not just not just a
position where you can find a good move
but the position where you you sort of
have a mathematical solution giving you
a very very large Advantage you
definitely get this vibe from from how
the bishop looks how the black pieces
are positioned here yeah the bishop
looks atrocious vulnerable to B5 so if
you go Rook 32 let's say yeah
one I mean there's just so many things
here Bishop one appears to be winning
material right so I I guess I have to go
to H5
Rook to H5 well eventually this movement
five is going to work yeah but also Rook
C7 like we don't have anything yeah if I
play roxy7 or H5 Rook C7 like what's
what's the follow-up why am I looking
great yeah why am I not just kind of
winning so Rook to C1 maybe I have to uh
try to find a trick with Queen to F6 and
say that Rook to C7 is going to be met
by root 2 E1
rookie one is actually a threat rookie
five for C1
rookie five and queen F6 Rook C1
queen of six yeah Queen F6
but my initial reaction is I will play
Knight E4 here okay let's not blunder
rookie one check unless we've mentioned
it uh just play 94 and then we'll see
seven I meant to show uh show what
you're sorry yeah yeah uh rookie one
check and the whole point is uh that the
queen uh requires the coverage uh of The
Rook on D1 so now four times
it's okay it's okay Roxy one what what
queen F6 yes and you wanted to play I
just wanted to stop now those those
things with rookie one the dead in the
track yeah next move and I don't know I
did a lot of Rook D5 though so the
Knight is I thought the night was
perfect on e4 but after let's say queen
E7 Rook C7 runs into Rook D5 so maybe
I'm not as well Queen D6 here looks
interesting yeah all of this looks like
we are on the verge of just winning the
game yeah everything everything by the
way F2 F4 Jan said hey look I mean The
Rook on C5 is terrible it yeah I have B4
B5 let me just defend four and seven
goes F6 straight away and now once again
it feels like there you know might be a
before fe5 and then Queen somewhere
looks interesting like Queen E3 or but
can't wait all the good stuff that we
had before all that yeah with the uh
with the trading of the f-pawns you know
must be favorable for white I mean it
looks domination uh Christian and by the
way linear yes uh has went straight into
that variation found the move A3 which
he had to find to maintain equality in
the position and now uh black mvl that
is has the very pleasant option of just
simply going Queen to C1 Queen to C4 and
making a draw with the black pieces
effortlessly
ongoing HG asking question and then
looks like King A2 might be the the only
choice there for linear to make a draw
so you can even ask one more question
and then take the same draw after that
yeah absolutely yes
you said found the movie three honestly
considering the fact that they're
repeating their own game 46. you know H5
H5 biling year does look like he knows
this is a draw
and he knows after Bishop C2 mvl will
know how to improve on their game from
last year so he's just asking the
question like are you sure you will you
will like do you know about H5 do you if
you don't know about H5 will you trust
yourself to go for this will you trust
yourself to allow HG and leave that pawn
on G6 as we're seeing right now on our
screen the pollen sticks is still there
that makes a lot of sense yeah I think
it's just one of those you know checks
yes that you that you go for against a
well-prepared opponent and if they know
they know yeah absolutely and it does
seem like Levon might actually be
winning right now yeah I was about to
ask because it's it's weird yeah it's uh
perhaps not he just played the move
Bishop takes H3 how do we feel about
this position
so this is the game where we just we
left it at Queen G4 is an interesting
move though just catching cutting the
juice we were singing praises to the
square G6 G6 says no G6 for you I will I
will play Bishop G5 and then I will
drive your going away but you were
saying I would very very much would like
to play Knight F4 and Lavon said me too
Knight to E3 yeah the Knight cannot
really be tolerated for very long we go
take Stakes Knight C4 and here Livonia
goes for this tactic Bishop G4 H3 I mean
you don't play H3 you've Bishop takes H3
is winning because that's the sort of
the first thing you will check right so
there is a clearly has some way of
dealing with this but Knight H2 is the
usual no I think like this direction it
does lose to F3 I think this is this one
that it works yeah yeah especially
because the bishop is we can perhaps
show this after GH Queen H3 I mean no if
you go to that H2 here I'm just a pawn
up no I can just take on D1 and go to B6
oh you oh you won upon I apologize yeah
so I mean I'm in GH GH GH green H3 nice
H2 for a second might look like we're
stabilizing queen of three coming next
move but F3 I think just wins here
exactly forcing you to take with the
Knight because it's hanging on H2 and
queen G2 here is quite strong
um it's quite sure and let the xf3 we go
rookie six sorry let's do that again F3
Knight takes seven nine takes a few
three and now with the queen still on D1
we go Rook E6 and I'm guessing rookie 6
is just a winning threat exactly uh but
but perhaps we can play so let's take
Knight takes D6 first I think we start
all of this from this moment we can take
on H3 first okay but let's just do it
Knight takes D6 Pawn takes Pawn takes so
we're threatening King H2 winning
takes H3 Knight H2 now Knight H2 rookies
or rookie six the thing is if you start
with Knight xd6 you also give me the
option of playing Queen to G4 Queen G4
maybe yeah then Knight to E1 and then I
can just simply take on D6 and be a pawn
up
you know this is quite clever yeah 91
seems to be the only move and it looks
like black has things hanging but in
fact after she takes D6 you cannot
actually win anymore King H1 but I don't
think that's going to help you tomorrow
because this isn't what I wanted I
apologize I will go I'll return to GH
yeah but then Queen takes H3 but my
guess is maybe after 96 maybe we don't
actually take on the six maybe we go
rookie six here let's go take on F7
let's go to G6 and how is this position
is the question you cannot play Knight
three uh G5
yeah that's a pretty line actually and
if you go knight seven we can play I
think you're just completely tied up if
you do this yeah
I've got Queen B3 check in the position
don't I yes but does it do enough
yeah and this one this one has been
drawn yeah as expected levonne and he
did not even take on Jesus yeah but he
knows so Queen B3 check well but what am
I doing here after King over am I
uh you've got a perp for pet right so
let's go look to a fate first guard the
F7 Square not only that but they also
have ideas of Rook to F6 followed by
rook hd5 and Rook to G6
whoa but probably H6 is still my main
threat your main go-to uh weapon here
right yeah this is a very very crazy
position because if your queen is not
coming to F7 it it doesn't feel like a a
playing for a win by white yeah the the
the how do you get out exactly the the
main thing I thought okay we need to
Queen F1 but let's say we just allow
this just to illustrate I don't know A5
Queen E2 A4 queen of one Queen takes F3
and it's a little bit and we've lost our
entire our entire cavalry's goals right
yeah we can't actually shoot the setup
you cannot lost the cavalry
so I can go H6 I can go King h8 I can go
Rook to F6 I'm still only going to yeah
this is such a bizarre setup
and if you go E5 I always have Rook to
F5 Rook F5 yeah we can we can play D4 D4
still doesn't compromise our position
very much but we would like to like play
five and then maybe Queen C2 to attack
The Rook on G6 but that will allow Rook
F5 which probably leads us to us
immediately resigning so it's such a
weird such a weird position and we do
have after Bishop I think we're going to
get there oh pardon me we do have G
takes H3 Queen takes H3 on the board n96
but now tonight is worse right that was
what this was the position I was trying
to achieve yeah that's what we wanted
with one that's right
Queen H4
King H1 I assume Rock to H6 and Rook H6
which is still fine okay
and now after Queen G2 we have yeah
we're just in time I think one more
temper for white and white completely
stabilizes yes Ed wins but okay uh we
did it was very important that we have
after
no King G2 Rook G6 check and King H1 I
don't have time for Rook H1 but I have
to say guys allowing Knight takes F7 and
Knight G5 and actually two knights on
the board yeah it's uh it's so difficult
but that was that was an amazingly
funny position where the knights were
frozen the queen was frozen and
everything was right yeah honestly if
there's anybody in the world who could
have gone for this without Lavonia
without home prep right I would have
definitely listed live on as one of the
people who could have actually gone for
them but even he and the end go see that
right somewhat regrettably but yeah it
was just too too much uh
perhaps a a fun-filled draw but uh it
feels like it's going to be uh well
still firusha has five minutes on the
clock so he needs to find sure Knight to
H2 is very natural but he needs to find
it in this position yes well in fact
there's no choice 95 might be a draw as
well what seriously I mean it's riskier
but it might still hold right Queen H4 I
go back
clean H4 you just go back Queen
h62 it might be very very similar to the
lines that we're discussing yeah are we
sure rookie five Knight of three rookie
six I was about to slide over six years
very strong though
I think we're just going to see a
repetition yeah just Queen H3 it looks
like this game is also about about the
end
the one is no that was exciting I must
say and then again uh uh I'm gonna go
home after this round and just plug this
Rook E6 Knight F6
Queen G4 immediately rookie five night
eight no not F3 rookie six nine actually
this mission is just winning for white
apparently Knight H4 covers everything
wow the one we were just discussing that
that doesn't work for black Christian I
just uh helped me out here uh clear my
cobwebs the two nights position yep how
did the what was the eval minus eight
it's over basically yeah how we didn't
see how to untangle so I think the idea
is to just go Rook to f8 not allow this
queen B3 Queen F7 right first and then
I'm going to follow it up with H6
King HH Rook to F6 and then at some
point I'm going to take on G5 follow it
up with Rook to G6 and you're not going
to be in time to defend minus eight yes
wow completely uh draw agreed by the way
and let's jump uh to the game between uh
Jan and Sam Shanklin when we left it and
by the way they're discussing that
variation right now clearly yeah yeah
very very clearly we we thought that Sam
was in deep trouble is that still the
case Peter I don't quite like what Yang
has done but he might still be better
because he has tactical resources it
looks like let's say Rook C5 will drive
the queen away but it loses straight
away to Knight E4 I think actually it
doesn't Queen takes A1 exists there's
Queen takes E6 oh it does lose yeah it
does lose right or right right just as
you it's suspected
very yeah and well and if you don't have
Rook C5 what are you supposed to do here
well it's nice no 95 you run into B3
before it's a kind of a strange position
where the white pieces also don't really
look like they are as firmly you know
ensconced in right but
I'm struggling to find squares for black
pieces more than I'm struggling to find
squares for white pieces precisely and
again this bishop looks so Dreadful B4
B5 on White's agenda yeah potential for
94. we're just gushing here because it
re-establish all the pins and the black
position
so we need a really good move for Sam
and I'm going to ask a Christian on this
one does Sam have a good move to rescue
what we think is a bad position yes
absolutely that move Knight to C5 now
there's a very important reason why
because after Knight to E4 Knight takes
E4 Rook takes d8 Queen takes d8 Queen
takes C6 King to h8 Queen takes C4 it
just looks like black is a pawned out
but this move Bishop to B7 allows him to
get more or less back into the game if
he manages to exchange the light Square
Bishops the king will be weak and I'm
going to have enough compensation for
the last Pawn you cannot take because of
Queen to D4 and this is uh The Motif in
the position that allows black to pretty
much survive in this game you can go
Queen to E3 after Bishop to B7 but after
Bishop takes G2 King takes G2 Rook to D5
uh this position seems to be more or
less okay it does feel like I have
enough compensation for the loss
very difficult move to make though
Bishop B7 it's such a visual yeah come
on Peter yeah but I think we're kind of
once again we're burying the lead there
a little bit because the point that I
think the reason you will not play
Knight C5 is not Knight E4 it's probably
B3 before at least initially and this
runs into 93 this way exactly yeah
yeah he played Knight B8 and he played
an idea I think might be a queen C7 he
is busted I at least that was my
impression
did that Knight C5 Bishop Beast Bishop
B7 you're you're doubled on the on the
diagonal you've got these seven under
control and Bishop yeah so that might be
a queen C7 on the board so after Rook C5
funny enough is still not completely
over so Rook to C5 you take on A7 yeah
we have one move away from winning like
if Knight gets back to E4 and now I have
the ridiculous move Bishop to D3 Bishop
David three that is nice so you're
covering E4 you've got the checks you've
got
why is this very nice help me out here
Peter I take it before
ah you just take D6 yeah it's a piece
yeah no I think Bishop D3 I would I
would like to play Knight E4
uh Bishop
takes E4
I'm somehow not losing anything I I was
worried myself everything is
we have Queen A7 on the board
yeah okay so let's find something
instead of that maybe you could give me
a check from D4 and then Rook to C2 yes
yeah you can give me a check I would
like to play Knight F2 but Rook C2 is
very strong so my idea was to play King
H1 yeah this doesn't look right
yeah yeah so we we go King H1 instead of
Knight F2 right oops excuse me for
checking H1 yeah but then Rook C2 anyway
black black achieves a lot of activity
Bishop D3 came in and you see uh young
uh full full in concentration because he
realizes
uh this activity here in the community
seven the the problem for white is we we
want a pawn but we also completely
misplaced our strongest piece King H1 is
the biggest test in the position for
black right now King H1
In This Moment
by the way when you think of peripheral
access what a move King H1
yeah that's not a museum no it's not no
not even close wow King H1 but B8 is
hanging on any capture so
it has a sense yeah if you if you
realize the move exists I think you can
come to the conclusion you want to play
it but just realizing you you have this
option is going to be it's not the the
first move that I want to say comes
together but but you move Knight E4
Peter it was just sort of like gosh
aren't you putting things on pre right
Knight C4 to stop Rook C2 seems much
more human
uh how does black respond to that one
Knight C4 idea of 95 obviously perhaps
Knight to C6 Knight C6
C4 I mean this is yeah some crazy stuff
yeah
what hold on C6 is hanging but D1 is
hanging here it's a draw but uh but it's
a draw white needs to make that's crazy
what a what a an amazing line Knight C6
and okay I'm going to amaze you even
more that's a king to H1 King to H1
sorry let me let me go back to the game
position this is a key moment King H1 go
ahead Chris the best move in the
position right now and the only one to
kind of keep the balance is Rook to D5
Rook to D5 okay okay I'm gonna some
p-day my Grandmaster title back any of
these moves come on the board we're
going to check their pocket exactly
let's let's just Rook D5 let's
disqualify some people now let's I'll
disqualify myself Rook just describe
okay that's a mind uh blowing move uh
once again taking advantage that you
cannot take on D3 least for the next
couple of moves you have to go root to
C1 first and if you do take on D5 the
Knight on D6 is going to be stuck there
but also the king becomes extremely weak
on it
exactly so I have enough compensation
somehow that is that
so there's quite remarkable
truly truly uh oh dear we're probably
not going well now that now that we're
here let me just ask the question yeah
this is what I was calculating I think
we've taken we go back to it and that's
that's probably the best and we go yes
yeah and uh
maybe give a check from B2 wait for you
to go King H3 and then go back to F6 I
was trying to figure out what I think
about this and I couldn't really come to
any conclusions but yeah now you don't
have um
somewhere so yeah it's uh
it's one of those where
you just get very very confused yeah you
just get very confused uh remarkable
okay let's not get too deeply uh wrapped
up on this game but what what a move uh
Bishop D3
what about Jeffrey versus Hikaru a game
we had because some kind of an example
exemplary King's Indian yeah and I
wanted to bring you back to this Peter I
let this game slip away from us so it
was a king's Indian where F6 F5 was came
so slowly on the board yeah but I don't
like I don't like Jeffrey's reaction I
feel like what he's doing is very much
playing into like the absolute maximum
that black ever gets in this structure
because this is now I understand it's a
king's Indian but you do actually
occasionally get positions like this in
the grinfeld yes which means that I have
an opinion about them this looks very
healthy for black I you know this just
looks like it's a it's a very decent uh
decent position
and in their head-to-head matchups uh
Hikaru and Rapid at least as a certainly
a big Edge a one win for Jeffrey so he's
Taste of blood for losses however and
five draws so they know each other
really well in this exact position rip
takes B The Simpsons has just been
played yeah I was wondering
throws the gauntlet down doesn't it
Knight H5 zika just says I don't care
about that you know concept of Queen
side doesn't exist you know Checkmate
ends the game only only the king side
really matters here the Knight is about
to land on a four and uh you you
really need some kind of reply to that
and I'm struggling to
to figure out what that could be I'm
looking at some ideas where I might end
up yeah I think you'd have to start
looking at that yeah something like dt7
straight away
not the 495 yes we're giving up on G
Lewis check but but maybe we don't get
mated and then maybe we have generated
enough in the center to at least
distract black from from the maid giving
but uh as Ben Larson might say nobody
believes us that's the other problem
right rookie Rook okay but okay I don't
but if we don't do that what do we do I
mean Knight F4 is going to come in with
incredibly uh painful effect for for
white
okay but at least I've got G2 covered
and let me uh what's going to cost us a
rook at least right and I'm not even
sure well I mean an exchange thank you
not not thank you Rook I I take it all
back but Ben told me I never get mated
with a knight on F1
and I do have two pawns that is fair
yeah that is fair I do have two pawns uh
in the immortal words of somebody show
me how good a compensation is this uh
Christian it's super double-edged and is
time going to be a factor it's a great
conversation time is definitely going to
be a factor because you know who the
more comfortable player is right now and
that is Hikaru with the black pieces
also 10 minutes on the clock 11 almost
11 on his clock and six minutes 40
seconds and counting for Jeffrey with a
devastating attack coming his way I mean
Knight to F4 Rook to G5 Rook to G8 you
have to find a way and this is exactly
what you are drawn to as a human push
the pawn he played the move D7 I think
no that was my end that was your move I
apologize that was that was uh we were
playing around with uh Jeffrey's uh
position objectively uh hikaru's
compensation is overwhelming it actually
gives him an advantage in this position
wow for the two pawns yes
uh take us through a line uh if you
would please Bishop takes C5 Knight F4
played Knight F1 now after E4
E4 yes dang okay
F take C4 right Rook to A1 I'm setting
up all the pins available in the
position Knight to H3 is a deadly threat
be careful Knight H3 check and Rook
takes F1
I have a feeling I've done something uh
dreadfully wrong and I this is
definitely the type of position that
Hikaru loves I think Jeffrey played
knife
is not thinking uh Knight to B3 what is
he intending to play against neither
four I wonder
yeah kind of similar with an iPhone B3
instead of a knight of an F1
or he he he wants to
I say sorry uh we don't have time to
take so Knight F4
and oh boy again G2 yeah we have to
protect G2 The Rook is unimportant right
not even say relevant on only two well
the good news at least we've covered day
one over day one yeah I think this maybe
is why he played Knight B3 because
neither one looks a lot Cozier so to
speak yeah you wanted to keep the king
tucked away but that Rook A1 was quite
the the delivery of uh bad news and they
have played Knight F4 Bishop takes C5
by the way just notice that uh Jeffrey
who oftentimes plays very languish
languidly you know just easy kind of
played Bishop takes C5 with a little pop
and uh quickness and it does seem like
that game between nepo and uh Sam is
gaining some traction uh and maybe even
finishing soon uh because
Knight to B7 Rook to C2 Knight takes d8
and our Rook takes G2 is on the board
yeah everything everything has been
played white has the option of taking on
D3 Queen F7 is a draw
Checkers yeah sure you you can start
with Queen to F7 first I think even King
takes G2 is only a Perpetual for black
but yes
Perpetual everywhere yeah my big
question is why not Queen F7 Knight
takes C6 and where is the Perpetual
there Queen to F7 was played
okay that looks like very very Salient
questions the queen comes down to F
no I have Queen takes you seven so no no
I meant Rook takes F2 King jiban I'm
getting mated me exactly yes I'm getting
whoa that Bishop before and you get made
it yeah you mean no Perpetual no
Perpetual here yeah but this was the
solution if white goes Rook takes D3 as
well and that could potentially be a
move in a position Rook takes D3 I go
Rook to G1 instead of like B6 that is
very visual that is very very cute
this is a very well-known construction
where the Rook only only parries the
church doesn't actually win for white
very cool way to finish the game
seriously I mean
that's yeah some will now remember we're
seeing some really sparkling tactical
yeah I mean this this looks like it will
be a draw but you can't really complain
about a drawing no with a rook G1 check
and that that mating construction
actually is pretty beautiful as well uh
Queen F7 check I played King h8 Sam
seems to be thinking uh does it make a
difference how do you give a Perpetual
against King takes G2
check
yeah that makes sense because you want
to keep the bishop right
but okay three Bishop of five G4 King H7
was played by the way King H seven on
the board okay apologies
King H7 Bishop King takes G2 gonna feels
very shameful but yeah the biggest
question I have is where's the Perpetual
where's the Perpetual here
okay
King H3
now this is what confuses me like I'm
I'm out of checks already and I assume
there is some kind of a spectacular
solution here but what is it
okay uh I thought let's start with D5
Queen to D5 yeah Queen D5 is a clever
clever way to do it yeah we need because
we need to have Bishop profile to check
I think we absolutely need to be able to
play Queen F3 check as well so King uh
Bishop H5 Bishop pardon me Bishop no
this starts looking risky yeah this
starts looking like and I'm marching to
to yeah
any of those moves yeah this looks like
we're playing for a Louvre for a loss
yeah exactly
wow okay perfect
because it's not over right
so you have to find F2 maybe I can try
to go towards F3 and then G4
yeah let's let's take a look at that
okay 25 check we go king after I assume
we provoke king queen D4 right you've
done it yeah 25 on the board by that but
by the way yeah King F3 King F3 Queen E4
check yeah well this probably loses to
King E3 King D2 and 2003 might be a
problem might be a problem we need to
calculate but it might be a problem
because I think I escape by the G4 yeah
D4 yes and there's no Knight C6 yeah
very very important to them the Knight
on d8 plays a very important defensive
role that's hilarious it is quite kind
of hilarious oh my goodness hilarious
yeah uh Ring Around the Rosies and the
Knight on d8 uh keeps everything so once
again King F2 and queen the [ __ ] of
three I only have Queen D4 yeah
King G4 okay we need to
Queen E2 oh once again because I want to
have Bishop to F5 you're absolutely
absolutely and we can give up this queen
but we are just not better we're not
happy I I've got the two Rooks but maybe
uh there's nothing good I mean rookie
one
rookie one I like that Rook D6 rookie
one okay I kind of uh I wanted to take
away the E2 squares 52 wasn't a
Perpetual but with the light on d8 I'm
like yeah makes me nervous yeah I feel
like I'm playing Toulouse here I really
complained to win I agree with that
in the meantime Hikaru somewhat
shockingly for me I actually chose to
pick up that exchange not that I don't
like his position right now I think it's
a perfectly good position it's just I
assumed he will continue playing for
mate but he yeah he didn't find anything
concrete and took on it too which
diminishes his mating opportunities but
he is up in exchange now of course
exactly
and these Knights feel a little bit uh
how do you say uh sensitive
um okay now having said that he just
played the move Rook B8 okay uh let me
play uh gross
uh continuing to move stuff away from
yeah I will eventually get mated I was
trying this side step
I keep on looking at something like H3
G3 E4
F takes E4 F4 trying to make sense yeah
but I do have a yeah and then F3 of four
and probably yeah
something feels a little yeah these
these violin Delights yeah even if I end
up doing I don't know I I it feels a
little bit dodgy for black maybe maybe I
understand what you're saying uh by the
way everybody what Peter wanted me to do
was uh capture this yeah I'm luring away
the porn and then I want to open up the
king side and if it does get opened it
still feels like white gets mated but
yeah you land with a with a with a bang
okay Young by the way refuses to to
allow a very simple Perpetual ghost king
of two I'm assuming with the intention
of going to a three and G4 so young is
just testing the waters Queen D4 check
King G2 actually oh he's going he's
going back to G2 he hasn't gone to F3
yet right
okay so this is actually just simply
ridiculous King to h8 was actually
losing why what
exactly that is the question that I'm
trying to answer for a very long time
um and once we see what they're going
King H3 uh didn't we say this was the
suicide variation I can take on F5 yeah
you can take on a five steel I don't
think he is Wars I think black pretty
much always will have to resort to
giving perpetuals but
and go back to G2 but yeah with this
light not on G8 with this Knight on some
kind of a Central Square
brilliant why does why the support
happen has two Rooks against the queen
so right you know if it stabilizes white
will win most likely but how how easy is
it to stabilize exactly
I'm very interested in something like E5
heavy 597 maybe I'm kind of looking at
ideas of bringing my knight in very very
quickly
definitely you need to expose
6.95 and then I start giving checks
exactly anything that brings the night
towards the king really doesn't look
like black is risking anything at all
and white might actually be risking
something here in some of these
positions because again the Knight is on
such a lousy Square on d8 we do have
Queen E4 check by the way a lighter E5 a
lot
I don't think this spoils it I think we
can still do it yeah we can still do it
in exactly the same fashion because
rookie seven Queen F5 check will allow
us to win this Rook under seven anyway
so if you if if Sam wants to include his
Knight he can do that I think I mean uh
a logical continuation here would be to
play Knight A6 okay but that does allow
us to bring light in to E5 just in time
seemingly we buy a knight F7 Knight F7
and either Knight C5 or night before
appears to be so each night is stronger
though
92 93 I'm kind of still uh yeah still uh
kicking up a fast as black for sure but
actually there's no there's no immediate
thread there I can go Rook C1 93 I think
just loses to rookie one I think this is
just a bad move because Queen G2 is
nothing
I think you play Queen E3 instead Queen
E3 and Knight D4 yeah you look when you
three check
we need to is bad because Knight E3 will
come up and
I'm not even sure what has Perpetual
there and king of 194 once again you you
start thinking you know maybe I should
have taken that draw that perhaps wasn't
offered at some point Queen D2 here Rook
G1 Rook CD one though
you're welcome to munch yeah I keep on
being torn but he did play he played he
played five and now 97 I very much like
the idea of playing my decision I did
too the moment you pointed it out I
actually liked it without the check by
the way on e4 I didn't think it was
absolutely vital but in any case you do
have Knight D7 yeah Fe 597 is 695 it
feels like black can never have you know
less than a Perpetual probably not more
than a Perpetual either but never
nevertheless yeah 97 on the board yeah
I'll shock you guys it seems like black
is just winning right now not not
shocking no winning there's no more yeah
no need for Perpetual anymore for black
he's just winning for black not shocking
sometimes you just overdo it
but but winning I I find that really
really strong like wow defend against uh
okay if I wanted to make it
it's just going to get picked up right
how is this a draw ah you have Ruby I
have this but I was going for a check
yeah the pawn is not survived I wanted
my palm
I got mesmerized there so takes Knight
D7
I would I I thought I had a bailout I
was wrong
it's a very exciting position but I just
want to make sure you know a reminder
two more games still ongoing shock is I
think much much better against Fabi and
hikaru's game is a mess yeah I have no
idea what's going on here
whoa I've just turned to the game
between Fabi and Shaq we are and
apologies kind of let this one slip
under the the radar but
first impressions are this is terrible
it's horrible like like really bad
there's nothing one is like what is
lodging a formal complaint yeah by the
way that's no way to treat a bishop
either the bishop at D1 with the pawn
structure of D3 E4 C4 and A4
what's my role uh the bishop is saying
where's my motivation
is also very very uh low on time it's
just going to be horrible to try and
Define this as you go Roxy 292 and then
what where is the night going yeah you
go Knight B3 Knight day one night
that's like a lot of moves yeah it's
like the the game of 15 yeah it's like
you gave me 50. there's this this game
where you know on a four four by four
square right yeah the tiles yeah by the
way Bobby Fischer was very good at that
he actually is maybe the world's best he
did it on the Johnny Carson show in like
30 seconds
it was like Johnny was amazed
um terrible position Christian
horrendous it's a trick there with those
you know 15 Withers is just to set up
the starting position which cannot be
solved and then watch them hang their
head against it it all stems back from
that moment when he played Bishop G3
instead of Bishop HD and allowed the
bind on the dark swear that and also I I
want to say I very much agree with you
Bish before just didn't seem right why
are we putting the bishop in front of
these three Bishop B3 and then F4 white
for choice no question here it just
looks to me like black is going to play
Rook G8 Rook G5 H5 H4 and eventually it
looks like you could very well start
today with two out of Two And So It
appears will will Sam and Sam if he wins
we'll we'll have won his first games
with the black pieces against
right and we were saying that Perugia
was starting with two whites who was
starting with two whites today yes
yes yeah uh Hikaru is now a piece up
against uh Jeffrey and I assume winning
because not only is he peace up there's
also a Pawn on H3 which means that he
can continue trying to give mate oops
Yeah things have
things have not gone well for for
Jeffrey in the American School we're
actually referring to these pawns on H3
and H6 is Alpha zero bonds yeah as as
that made it into your Lexicon
absolutely yeah yeah you do you do feel
like uh you see a lot more of them these
days Carl made the move on four seconds
there yeah yeah you do have to be a bit
careful in the position it's not that
easy no it's it's not immediately
obvious that this is winning for sure
yeah but you you still feel like it
should be after night this is Queen D5
this is uh actually just uh just okay
yeah yeah very very nice nice save Bye
by Jeffrey then yeah I didn't realize
Queen D5 was as strong as that yeah
played once again in four seconds but
now we can play B6 I guess and just
continue pushing yeah
and very importantly you would like to
play something like E4 followed by Queen
B2 or queen A1 check but it always runs
into Bishop D4 so you don't have that
option pretty much pretty much ever so
B6 looks like a very good starting move
if you and uh in the meantime Jan's King
is about to go on a walkabout and yeah
that generally doesn't end well uh well
at some point I'm going to go Queen F6
or at least five yeah I think I think
the light on G8 is just going to fall
yeah yeah Knight C5 check I was looking
at Knight C5 check followed by Queen
Quincy seven or six yeah yes yes because
the game will be on the C file so Queen
C7 will also introduce the idea of
discover checks with the Knight on C4
that's completely winning and he's done
it he's played Knight C5 and as you say
Sam is having quite the day
wow
yeah
it's okay to C4 Jan will not be a
particularly happy bunny about this game
because he was he was so much in control
from the opening through that I'm gonna
just jumped back to the Hikaru position
for a moment because he did not play the
move B6 which was he played he played a
four instead a very concrete option uh
trying to win some Pawns in the center
but yeah as well as setting up with the
boys we just seen Knight E4 what do you
think of them apples if you think don't
they have I think he's in trouble now
because bishop ef4 and you get mated
bishop
f-a-e-f4 and you get made it you're
gonna get made it yeah
Who tricked whom F4 just didn't seem
right it felt like you should not be
touching anything on the king side like
you don't give squares to those pieces
well most especially the night you don't
invite the night close to the king I
wasn't even happy honestly I was looking
at this and I was thinking even the fake
queen E5 King H7 I would much rather not
allow any of them but EF just wins
Bishop fa Queen f8 even that position I
was I thought not higher the camper why
are we giving black so many squares like
if this queen now jumps out somehow to
somewhere like before we're just gonna
get mated yeah but hikara found a much
uh cleaner cleaner solution I would
assume yeah Bishop f8 E5 takes F4 and
Hikaru is ready for Carlos in 15 seconds
but he knows yeah he knows he played
Knight
with the intention and there he goes
there it is yeah
there it is and there's also going to be
six threats of uh of made from that side
as well like if you play Queen jiban you
get mated by Queen B6 which is
unfortunate like you would maybe hope to
be able to play Community one and just
continue the game somehow but it's still
over I think uh Jeffrey just has that
look of you know you're startled by the
fact that you're just eyeballing Queen
A1 made and that's just is this hikaru's
first win no it's his second win it's
just that he said many losses
is uh
he did win against Levon and in the
meantime uh yeah yeah
position continues looking horrendous he
did make like that night that was on B1
and had no sweats
yeah give him credit for that one how
did that happen Okay we left it here and
uh yeah it happened because uh uh shock
went for something very very concrete
and appears to now be what is Chuck
doing oh okay that that question takes
F4
that's a visual
yeah it looks very beautiful but appears
not to be winning yeah because four
seconds okay yeah you can see too yeah
you can take onitsu and play
Rook takes E5 G4 maybe [ __ ] F3 yeah
we're just saving this now oh my
goodness that would be uh we've seen
some miraculous saves
uh and hinji too not the tempo that we
expected that doesn't look right that's
not the tempo we expected
uh see it works still works Rook takes
equals if you take me The Rook I take
only two and yeah he took on H7 I don't
like Rook takes H7 though I thought we
really needed to take only two and play
King of three first well by the way this
is a it's a girl
yes
I think DJ C2 King to have three attacks
all of yours yes and now without the
Rook on H1 and by the way Jeffrey
resigned as a Hikaru uh bounces back but
what's happening in this uh Fabi
position after King D6 what has been
played
what happened by the way I think Nebo is
also about to resign yeah it does look
does look completely and utterly
resignable there
hold on we have this yeah let's let's
take a look at five's position yeah he
never took on each he didn't he didn't
take on it this is this is what we'll be
discussing here I think he now kind of
gets mated on the king side like because
he the bishop only two is still alive so
yeah you you get shuffled towards the H
file and then those two Bishops are
going to be a huge big problem in
particular on before checking F2 Rook a
fortune kind of squeezing it into the F4
Square
I think he's going to play Bishop E3
even something like King C5 here looks
very logical just kind of pass the move
over to to fight me again and say you
know like
um well I'm thinking Rooker for
championships
that was my first instinct exactly I'm
wondering why this hasn't appeared yet
yeah the King E5 I have rookie seven
Rook they see two no King C5 King C5 on
C5 it's completely impervious to all the
checks I just like C5 as a square yeah
but uh yeah maybe Rooker 4b3 is just
more straightforward yeah yeah King C5
there we go it's just such a nice quiet
I know no see forces 20 seconds yeah
is a little bit uh shamefully
embarrassed yeah and now there's no
check from H5 either so we can play Rook
F6 or like any Square
once again
Bishop E3 get maybe make room for the
yeah absolutely yeah
and then uh
going back to some squares and indeed he
has done it yeah that's just what I
prescribed Peter that's what I thought
was interesting at least Rook H3 bishop
or Bishop D1 maybe maybe it's time to
actually admit our mistakes yeah
okay but this is such a much better
version than with the Rook on A1 with
the Rook on H1 there is no Rook F1 ideas
I think he might now be taking this draw
or at least gaining some time with it
yeah I mean there's not much risk for
black but it's also difficult to see how
you're making progress there should be
three we can take only two and go rookie
one so that doesn't win
for starter for starters you can maybe
take on C4 yeah I think Tech C4 would be
a
we just pick up the pawn and go from
there yeah
as you say a good start indeed
and it looks like Shaq is not ready to
acquiesce to the draw either Rook to E6
well he doesn't really he will always
have that Perpetual I think he very
clearly recognizes that yes there's no
that's not a running away very hard to
imagine a scenario in which he doesn't
have that Perpetual uh available to him
at all times so
uh is is
a clever move I think yeah it's the
clocker factor uh well both are on very
low time shock is actually in 20 seconds
against 50 for five years so if I be
recovered on the clock as well he was at
some point in Desperate Straits in terms
of
cloud of the cloak situation yeah
it should be four I'm amazed it wasn't
inclined towards the Pawn King takes C4
it keeps on declining that invitation I
know I guess he doesn't like the idea
that the king can be checked from H4 and
he just doesn't like the idea of his
skin getting checked at all but
he probably wants to play D3 D2 and then
kind of go from there
I think which is a this is a sound sound
plan like his next move if white does
nothing king of two is not nothing king
of two specifically stops the 3d2 from
happening you can take on D1 and play G2
so I'm guessing you're not you don't run
any risks but Rook F6 is to Chase the
king back
I like this one for King 33. yeah
go back
don't go too F4
yeah that thing can get a bit uh
adventurous whoa who did it he went to
F4 where is he going okay it's really
yeah now he's imploring him to take the
bonus decision made absolutely no sense
yeah I don't know what was King Apple
and by the way Sam won the game yeah
what a turnaround for
Sam was in Dire Straits we felt yeah
some will be tied for first
after this round I feel right if I if
I'm not mistaken because MBL MBL drew a
firoza Drew haptic through our wild card
what can I say yeah great decision by
our committee uh to invite Sam as a wild
card player King F6 where is it where's
babies going with us with a very cunning
trap yes C5 Rook H4 mate mate got to put
that one on the board
uh yeah don't step into the mate don't
step into the mate and just
sidestepping the deadly king of F7
attacking Rook
yeah I'm not sure I'm not sure what's
going on here I I would have played you
to uh some time ago to begin with and
you probably have to go back now right
yeah you probably have to play Rook H1
and
and the thing is with with the white
king cut off on the f file I think I'm
very happily just going into those two
against two end games and probably
winning some of them which is why I'm so
interested in the idea of playing G2 and
then just taking on D1 going rookie one
absolutely forcing you to take on G2
you're just playing on yeah exactly I
really don't like that I mean he will
probably play why are we bringing the
king back into into yeah
knows that it wasn't really doing very
much out of six here unless he goes King
Rook hunting king of five
yeah this is uh
then I I again I'm gonna air mail my GM
title
yay I like why isn't this enough to
already five it wasn't F2
okay and now it's about to return to uh
like like ages and somebody please play
D2 yeah why is that pawn not only two
yet
um please play D2
and by the way King F2 denied yeah
denied
requests denied rookie seven okay but
now I can go King to D4 no it is hanging
I don't know it's hanging on no but then
Luke takes you to Bishop takes it I
think that's by this point we will jump
at this opportunity exactly I'm not
happy but I think it's an improvement
Maybe
maybe I don't know also unless you get
checkmated right there's a very yeah we
could get checkmate in there actually
yeah
Bishop D1 we're being informed I assume
with the idea of 3D 3D and then King C4
King B3 King C2 sometimes yeah because
the king is yeah I keep on I keep on
agitating for actually doing this and
shark keeps on saying nah not interested
so I don't know how likely it is to
finally appear on the board but I I
really really struggle to understand why
this yeah he's going for it finally yeah
this this could have been done ages ago
with the King on F6 we could have had
this bishop
and The Rook on the eight I remember
king would be as you said before and I
think here the problem is King D5 I was
trying to figure it out because even
after Rook takes before before we get
looking C4 again
is completely lost because of how far
the white king is I think I think it's
just dead yeah I would not want to argue
with you on that one that just looks
terrible so I think we go King G5 and
white yeah you just like whatever your
choices are here they're all ugly you
can play rookie 2 and play a different
version of the same end game it's still
going to be horrible so what if I go
King uh Rook to G4 C5
it might be a problem yeah you're just
kind of stuck you you don't have really
have any weights and to further improve
yeah
okay I'm going to be also playing yeah
but I think before you eventually like I
will take with the game on G3 play C5 C4
and only after that I will go King
seducing takes B2 and C3 yeah that's a
losing end game yeah I don't think this
this engine can be held yeah I'm pretty
sure Ruka follows this I think the best
chance might be something like Rook G4
or yeah
because I wanted in this position to
play Rook H1 and start threatening some
checks but
you know like you know here the issue is
we are defending very passively for now
Shaq has no weigh-in but I guess you
just go over here
I love that move rookie eight and rookie
one yeah I don't know I don't know why
he's continuing to delay it wait a
minute King if I can I take on B4 now
this is an improved version but you
might still be losing
but I think you have to go for a massive
opportunity no he didn't go for it I
thought that was a great opportunity for
King E4 might have been at the end uh
problematic because yeah it's okay it
may have still still have been very
dangerous but
wow why this Rook has not gone to E8 and
E1 will remain a mystery yeah do three
B3 is now threatened yeah he's going
after the B3 pawn and uh it's a very
solid plan yeah so let's go look H Rook
H3 king of two but then we wish yeah
king of two Rook D3 how are you
how are you supposed to hold this yeah I
don't know and go for some kind of an
fnh yeah no G1 okay okay is there
something okay is there a checkmate
yeah this is definitely an improvement
certainly uh
okay Fabiano somehow might escape this
one which this would be would be a
miracle Escape actually it would be like
three miracles in the same
in one round
in the same game well Chuck says I'm not
worried about your checks you only have
one that is Meaningful and then I will
play rookie one and win more material
okay so let's give a check Rook G5 Rook
G5 only move 55 King F6
25 for K1 yeah Rook D5 on the board and
as you see but then we can take 22 and
it's an improve definition yes but I
think it still ends up being F I think
we still lose the
Rook G3 not allowing there's no more
wait but can I take Rook takes B4 and
what am I doing we definitely
yeah
so we take on before we take on C5 and
we make a draw right I think so I think
so yeah it has to be a draw
in that position
I'm okay with this yeah B3 or B5 and
then I start pushing the A5 no age check
yeah we don't like this music it doesn't
feel like the right direction for
Fabiano
King E7 even here because uh yeah that's
a king E7 is a nice way of stopping the
other Rook from getting into five king
of seven yeah
now your Rooks are very badly placed
yeah I don't absolutely one is uh on tap
uh-oh uh oh Rook takes before did look
like it was you know a very good real
great opportunity Rook at five jack King
G7 I think uh this game it's time to go
room d61 back
well then C4 C3 yeah then the the other
one starts coming in yeah it's uh and
the bishop by the way will play a
defensive F6 oh yeah that that is sort
of clever because
with two seconds on the clock hold on
there's C4 C4 stops the Perpetual
because we will cover f8 we cover a fade
here yeah we there's only one check
that's not scary
it didn't scare Shaq yeah
shy is doing things mostly correct yeah
I I think what like I think he lost the
thread a little bit he somewhere moved
into respect but since then his
decisions have he's picked up
very very on point there's still no
Perpetual we can play C3
right Rook B5 there's no way to stop C2
now yeah
C3 and push him baby
yeah I think uh this might spell game
over not only that but uh
after Rook B5 we also have or maybe no I
apologize
amazingly Rook D7 was really the the
move that that lost it even after Rook
of seven King G8 the the move Rook uh if
F1 or even Rook F3 was still holding
which is kind of a shocker for me it
doesn't look like you should be holding
that but he was still fine
he's no longer fine now but he was still
fine at that moment so so how do you
have eight is that some something to be
said or do we just start with Rook G2
rojito King F3 and then C2
G7 maybe just to kind of not have to
worry about that at all after King F3
yeah yes uh exactly forward now I guess
we play [ __ ] too yeah now yeah Rook
takes before a b is not nothing yeah
just place it to you
it's one check we don't have to worry
about very much exactly one check and we
block the check
and he's reaching for yes situ is on the
board Rook to B8 Bishop to f8
and there's no continuation yeah it's
just it's just a queen yeah
it's not only one Queen that's the
problem yeah it might be too there's a
couple of Queens coming anything to be
recommended for a night check uh
no no no definitely not definitely not
definitely not take get the queen no we
yeah
no no he's not gonna make a knight get
the queen with one second on the clock
no he played that move with one second
no one second are you kidding me yeah
and it goes via the B4 square and hides
on A3 basically this is this is how you
win now
it goes in that direction or if you if
you give a check from the G8 Rook it
goes to like G5 H4 G3 h2g1 yeah this is
over yeah this is just gone
in this game
had a drama and five parts I mean my
goodness so a lot of people are kind of
streaking today uh uh Sam won his first
two uh shark won his first two and uh
Bobby
loses loses his first stone
well
what yeah we're being told that this
this was a drama entirely and it no
longer is about Rook gf8
seems to have been a draw at that point
this is very ah yeah we because we
cannot go to G3 we cannot go to G3
because we get checkmated oh okay yeah
oh my God
oh my God this is oh well this is what
you were saying that he's gonna hide his
King on A3 and Shaq immediately pointed
out where was the drug Christian he's
showing it yeah he thought he was losing
between H5 there but then the group
comes back to C8 we can show I know what
I know what they're discussing please uh
yeah I know what they're discussing if
we can bring up the
what position they're discussing the the
point that Fabi didn't do it because he
thought the King goes to whoops yeah it
doesn't matter uh this will just take a
bit longer
but this is the position Rook G8 King H4
Rook h8
and either King G3 or queen H5
immediately he thought this was
basically winning because black has an
extra an interposition and he thought
this is resignable but the rubius goes
back to C8
ah so you don't go Rook G8 and take on
G2 because they're C1 you don't have to
take it yeah and uh I assume he just
felt this this position was lost but
it's Rook CA just dropped very makes a
very trivial draw actually here just
King D3 oh my goodness and I assume the
winning plan was like how was this
winning then
this is another interesting question
what was
why was this not a draw to begin with no
that was a draw D1 is the wrong move he
won Queen Israel D1 Queens was the one
yes okay so yeah he should have played
C1 Queen no you have to start with King
G7
and when you go Rook takes f8
now I give a check first and now my King
has time to move towards the C5 so if
you go here
oh
no not allowed no and if you take the
one Queen if you go here of course I get
the second Queen you don't want to do
that and if you go to F2
C1 I have a feeling in this much silver
draw right yes this is a draw no never
mind it's still a win but we can start
with 24 check which is very very good
that King G7 and rook and rookie two
sequence
and it might have been wow it might have
been the only way if you start with C1
Queen right this is a dry as well also
yes there's no way to escape the tracks
remarkable
what an end game
and I would assume no you cannot start
with Rook to E2 because then I just
simply take you don't have D1 so you
have to start with either King H7 or
King to G7 wait for the Rook to take on
f8 and then give this track on E2 what
we keep that reminds me of the ferruges
amazing we keep on we keep laughing
moments these studies crazy it's just
absolutely absolutely wow
let me tell the people about the
chessboard that I've got in front of you
this is
um uh St Louis rapid Blitz uh tournament
standard chessboard that's available at
Q Boutique absolutely it's a premium
20-inch window roll-up board featuring
the official GCT logo uh uh yeah uh as
you can see there it's uh the other way
around it's still it's still the same
logo now it's and now it's the right way
up wow burgundy and cream squares uh two
and a quarter inch uh perfect for on the
go and travel and as yasa said available
on uh
cubicstl.com so do hacks will travel
very important to have one of these
and let's take a look at a look at our
standings
today look at the shop shark is not
tight for six and five being dead last
wow so at the top there alireza made two
draws today MBL one one and Drew one and
Sam caught up with them by winning two
games with black impressive impressive
Gianna's Jana's back to title fourth
within year who made two draws the one
also made two draws Shakira is back to
uh that is minus one right let's say
around here that's minus one but who
wins uh certainly improved his position
but um let's let's go on a brief break
and then the final round of rapid and
then two full days of Blitz ahead of us
so tomorrow and day after tomorrow will
be a lot of fun
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back and one final round of
Rapid is ahead of us with this being the
standings prior to the game starting uh
three players three players in the lead
there alireza mvl are being joined Now
by Samsung who's having a stellar day
two out of two with the black pieces
both of his wins coming with the black
pieces first against Hikaru and then
against uh Yankee just now and these are
our standings and our pairings for the
90s yeah it's okay uh what a day we've
had Peter and what bearings we've got in
store for this our final round the all
French match-up yeah you like them
apples first and foremost yeah two
people in the lead play each other right
now uh MBL uh with white against that
areas and the games have started this
would be a Berlin which is bringing a
lot of joy to you know me personally
I'm kidding and there is also at the
bottom there there wasn't yeah exactly
yeah a tale of two cities so to speak
yeah player on two out of two playing
somebody who has no points so far today
also yes it is Hikaru versus Fabiano
started with C4 E5 A3
whoa well I mean Sicilian is a good
opening
okay this is probably not a good sign
everybody I've probably seen the long
game you know I think we've seen this
movie before
well they they you you have to assume
they have been uh potentially maybe
working together a little bit MBL
definitely was very instrumental in
bringing alireza to France yes uh
they're in very very good terms and
they've had a bit of a shaky-ish day I
would assume so yeah deciding to you
know wrap up the record portion a very
very eventful uh day I must say of Rapid
chess will end in a whimper uh in this
one and uh Christian even though the
games just got underway you were saying
that between
um
Fabi and Hikaru we have a A3 English
absolutely let's just look at this uh
reverses yeah reverses reverse
this uh seems to have been a two-minute
game it's kind of kind of long for this
particular opening wait I mean we've
seen this done faster this is not this
is not the record two minutes because
the Arbiter is interfering yeah I mean
they would have been already gone right
yeah I think I think the proper
punishment for doing this to us would be
to get mvl into the studio and just to
get him to comment down the rest of the
road that feels Fair yeah I think I
think that happened yeah let's just get
him here and not allow him to leave
until the round is over
just uh
so this is the proper way alireza points
out that with Queen D6 with that move
yes
they are off I'm gonna bring up the game
between Hikaru and Fabi tell me about
this move a2a3 it's just I mean we're
sorry we're playing as a cylinder we're
just playing a sicilian and uh in
response uh Fabi chose to play some kind
of a
um
the the D3 Bishop D3 uh Danny kopex
particular what it's called when it's
played by white yeah right it does you
know it it generally offers nothing to
White right and here uh hikara will have
the same position with the national
Temple of a2a3 which is generally a very
useful move in most kinds of Sicilian
positions so I think Hikaru will be
quite happy with the with this outcome
it's just a slow maneuvering position
why it will not really have okay well
fair enough to take us where the action
is uh well there's some action in the
game between Miami and Dominguez but
that one seems to be bittering out as
well into some sort of an equal
situation now it started off very
promising after this move F4 Bishop to
G4 we saw this bishop takes a F7 check
the problem is that this allows after
Queen takes G4 Knight takes G5 you don't
want to take back with the queen on G5
and allow the exchange of the Queens
because after that long Castle is going
to come and black structure is much
healthier so what white needs to do is
keep the king in the center the problem
is I have a way to force this long
Castle to happen on the board after
Queen to C8 Queen to G3 Queen to D7
there is a long Castle coming on the
board and after G6 long Castle this is
the position that we have and by the way
the players are just simply blitzing
this this might be something that
they've analyzed both of them at home
Rook takes D6 GTX H7 this is the
position we have on the board Dominguez
still blitzing out his moves this is
move 20. he has 27 minutes on his clock
wow 26 minutes for my media of both of
them really really studying uh their uh
theoretical uh battle right now and
after root 25 G6 it does seem like black
is doing quite well in this game well I
was just going to say that also the the
the speed with which the move Knight C6
to d8 came on the board as me convinced
that this is actually still crap
extraordinarily enough but Lanier we
know linear is a great uh theoretician
but to prepare this deeply well I I find
that extraordinary I really do I don't
think he got surprised in any of his
games linear that is
even in a field like this he still I
think stands out as somebody who has in
particular in his own lines who has
absolutely encyclopedic knowledge of of
everything and is extremely well
prepared uh he still somehow manages to
often have three minutes so by move 25
right with 20 Blitz doubt but right well
yeah he he is an unbelievably
well-prepared player and uh who has
plenty of plenty of knowledge I want to
say that nepo is one of those players
that when things go well it's great when
things go badly it's terrible is he on
tilt he's up against levonne and Roni
and does Levon it's not it's not obvious
yet but I mean so far they've also
played out a kind of a fashionable
London uh London variation uh both of
them clearly aiming for a very uh
similar position none of this is new
we're still Queen the xc5 appears to
have been weirdly even though it's the
most obvious move in the position recap
until until then we were following some
very high profile games but they're both
playing very very quickly uh black has a
solid structure but why that is for the
time being controls the one open file
sure so gotta be worth something right
yeah you would assume what has some sort
of pressure here but it's
not that much I guess but yeah I
wouldn't really enjoy this with black I
would I would think right we're looking
at the move Knight on D2 to F3 simply
reinforcing the the Knight on uh E5
perhaps planning to play something like
Rook C6 force that Queen trade Queen
season double double on the C file and
just well that's uh that's nice for
white but we have a special guest who's
come all the way uh into Studio to take
over our jobs absolutely Peter it's so
nice to have Maxine with Christian Maxim
first of all a good day for you at the
office an important Victory with the
white pieces against Fabiano to start
off the day and after that you uh tame
the the games how do you feel about your
performance
yeah I think it was good especially um
that came again with Fabi like I had
this little ideas in the Berlin Game
turned out
much better than I could how difficult
it is for black because of course with
the engine we could see the eval and it
was saying zero zero zero but how
difficult it is to actually make a
drawing that yeah so I think the first
real mistake is H4 like in terms of
practicality because when my Rook is on
F5 it cannot join
uh I mean with a Pawn on H5 yeah uh
after age four I get hook F4 so H4 is
still a weakness so his organ H7 is
still tight now the difference is I can
go wrong B4 I can go okay for I can go
root G4 and Rook D7 and we need some
more weaknesses on this side yeah and uh
then I even got a better version of the
king E6 I actually bought this book to
default the other two F2 because then
from F2 I also control F7 pawn and and
their A4 was also very nice like in
terms of practicalities what is the idea
behind A4 just to yeah just to foresify
actually I wasn't sure with B4 before
was also an option because my first
intention would have been Rook fd2 but
there
uh you can just wait because after all
these seven does Rock C8 yes
so
so let's say five of these seven look to
ca yeah and then so after so before was
also an option but here I thought this
was great because King E7 Rook C4 this
is what I want basically before
and this is false yes yeah also computer
still holds it but
so a practical perspective is not yeah
and he took on E5 yeah now it already
felt like his skin okay it felt wrong
but uh B6
take take and look the idea yes they
they go to d8 and try to create some
counter play yeah I thought there would
have changes but of course I keep
computer holds it it's very possible but
you have to look d8 I think that he
played I think it's more or less over
absolutely and you executed perfectly
after that you play this game that you
already played before against yeah
exactly linear decided to change with H5
with H5 yeah and there
um I didn't remember anything except
that it should be good but I managed to
to find this idea with Quincy 22 yes
which is quite nice
and then at the end I was considering
playing on so this was a critical moment
did you guys discuss at the end after I
think yeah we did so first I wanted to
take on G6 after A3
yes because Queen F6 is still not
possible because
yeah and King A2 which was his intention
is the best move but then I win attempt
a full Tempo so I have opportunities
even though it showed me like he
probably knew Queen C4
King B1 Queen D4
Queen F6
hook C1 take Queen D3 King A2 Queen F3
and yeah like he told me this line and
sorry yeah
she should be a draw summer but I was
concerned wrongly I must say after each
take G6 about Queen E2
because I always thought
like rookie eight Queen D2 quindito
they're short of okay five actually
loses The Rook to H though yeah so this
I was concerned about but
turns out this is actually better for me
and more importantly there's even a
better version of the queen E2
uh like
but anyway would have gone king2 so it
didn't make a difference yeah but Queen
C1 here
King A2 Queen C4 Queen takes Pawn text
home D2 engine means that they have C3
hook H2 F6 and I'm just much better yeah
so I'm misunderstood this end game
because I thought I can actually be in
danger and that's why I didn't take on
G6 absolutely but he probably knew like
H5 was a semi Bluff Yeah by him allowing
you to equalize if I now constitute it
to yeah or find which you did yeah and
then in the last one against alireza
yeah like they were I had too many
birding games so too many too many ideas
were shown already and I was like
yeah since you finished so early I think
the boys want to take you on a tour of
what's happening in the other games
maybe you can help us uh analyze guys
let's watch the leader I mean the
co-leader yeah that's your job uh we'll
uh we'll jump into the game of uh Sam
Shanklin who happens to be sharing the
lead going into this last round uh with
you it's one of these mimzo Indian
positions uh your take on uh very old
school old school like you don't see
these structures very much anymore I'm a
bit surprised uh uh Jeffrey was so kind
of blase about opening the a file I
thought they for I guess a485 he was
worried about C5 breaks no question
about it yeah because there's otherwise
there's absolutely no reason not to play
the movie 7a5 here
I'm sure it was uh some kind of C5 bc5
and then something uh very often the
spawn just gets given away to to open
some some squares for your pieces right
if three Bishop B5 or Ruby one or
something but what about the position
right now after Rook A7
Jump Right In uh Maxine what do you
think of this position would you prefer
white or black and why
also please you lost Maxi no no Maxim is
still here
we go we expected to jump in and uh lead
away uh sure like if you know the answer
just Shout It Out Maxine sure he's
thinking people are allowed to think
no I must say that today some some
opponents I'm not showing him I've not
been showing him enough respect so far
Jeffrey uh
sums up on us so bossy and
andyan
and uh actually wrongly so because he
improved tremendously so and he's been
playing very well what do you think
about the position maxi what do I think
I think
um
I mean Jeffrey apparently knows what
he's doing
I would be pretty scared with black but
again I don't have
any knowledge of this position
um
could he wants C5 here with black
with the idea King C7 and see 4c5 is a
very scary uh scary thought I know yeah
I was wondering about Knight H5 but we
might just get mated right we play
Knight let's just look at some lines
yeah let's go Knight H5 I don't know
Queen A4
C5
like it's very it's very easy to imagine
this just meeting being made you know
with like Rook 8 and Bishop A6 or Rook
B7 and Bishop Basics I'm currently I
think Knight B8
ah maybe it still loses right my B8
would be seven or at least it's very
scary it might be eight rooms is yeah
simply Rook B7 King B7 C6 check I think
it's over 96 Bishop A6 and also no like
King A7 there Bishop before ah 95. yeah
yeah and queen C6 you don't have time
yeah
probably I got slightly over excited
there but this just to illustrate just
to illustration
how quickly you get mated if things go
there's a reason I I propose the move C5
and you rejected it no no I just wanted
to show how scary it is and then we can
discuss good moves which are which
you're suggesting no it's just just a
demonstration uh when a foreign
yourself tied up a little bit right yeah
I didn't really want King C7 I was
wondering about Knight B8 for instance
Knight B8 yeah
this is very scary to me I don't know
wow uh so let's keep going Bishop yeah I
don't know if I want Queen D7 or queen
C7
probably the latter actually if contact
C5 is not a threat
three Knight C6 sword yeah
I mean I can win the F7 Pawn but that's
maybe not oh yeah yeah you can yeah I
mean
forgot about that bad boy not in love
with what we're doing here with black if
I'm honest there's also rugby rugby
seven King B7 GC looks kind of
interesting at least let's put it like
this yeah rugby seven King B7 D takes C5
okay okay okay it is strong yeah I
missed that just uh in time in time
wow uh but it goes to show that there
are some very dangerous attacking lines
here for for for white yeah I'm still a
bit confused as to as to why we allowed
this so comfortably with Blackie I
thought this
this I mean no matter how unpleasant
a5c5 is this looks scarier right right
but then I mean like Jeffrey is you know
modern generation of players maybe we
can also go after Queen A4 E5
E5 I just look everything though now
yeah trying to but I'm scared about and
Bishop E2 G4
like trying to
Bishop D3 Bishop of five King E2 rookie
I don't know it's uh yeah I mean yeah it
looks Knight B8 played by Jeffrey a kind
of an acknowledgment that things are
things need to be addressed at least
yeah yeah I think it's scared no I mean
Knight B8 makes sense yeah absolutely
yeah it's just because c5dc probably you
won't
will be meeting C5 with a capture
because you can't allows he takes B6 for
sure
so perhaps let's start with Queen wave
not even even here yeah Queen A4 now and
then Knight C4 and
still
um frightening I'm very very frightened
but maybe Knight H5 is still okay
somehow because if we get if we get rid
of the bishop on G3 there will be much
fewer pieces giving us made okay I'm
gonna be super greedy why not I go
Knight D5
no I like Knight H5 actually Knight D5
or 90. go for C3
yeah
this might be a bit too green
asking for the world Christian
nice but Knight H5 I like this idea too
just get rid of this just
night on ph is formidable yeah it's a
very good Defender for sure yeah and the
the maneuver that I very much want to
show is like Bishop H2 yes there is a
draw
but also kind of a cute idea that might
be yeah
H5 97 I thought 97 is quite strong uh
you want to yeah five I am actually
getting rid of that Bishop right but 97
Rook H1 are you like uh really you're
gonna you're gonna self pin yourself
like this
G4 G3
like G4 Knight C4 G3 you were telling a
story the other day yeah
I mean g4g we remember there was a bit
Yeah
your trainer was like taser
luckily for me not mine yeah yeah I
cannot make anything work so yeah I
didn't work with that particular about
but it was a nice story I like the story
uh C5 too optimistic
did he play Queen he played Queen A4 for
now yeah he is not committing to excuse
me to anything just yet after 9 B8 so
wait Queen A4 Knight C6
I guess he wants some sorry yeah I guess
yeah probably the immediately five yeah
you need C5 yeah so we go C5 Knight D7
absolutely for us because otherwise
we'll take this seven is a winning
attack yeah so we take that Rook
which one do we prefer I would say take
on A7 yeah I think I think if he wants
to give mate we have to take on A7 yeah
okay yeah so uh Bishop A6 is on your
agenda you get that but
killer G takes and now Knight C4 or
fortnite D5 right yeah s195 seems to be
stopping mine yeah probably but Knight
T4 Knight D5 Knight E5 actually oh yeah
and then it's basics
like E5 so this stops Knight takes B6
check ideas
very scary still
dope
very scary you know I don't know this
looks amazing I mean F6 if six Bishop
Basics Fe is currently uh that I still
get mated so C6 and Knight C6 yeah might
be a problem well oh excuse me Bishop
Knight takes C6 Bishop C6 Bishop A6 well
that's not made six continuously it's
close to me though it's close to me but
it's ah queen queen yeah it is made
actually yeah Mission B5 now and there
was a reason you wanted to get rid of it
wasn't there I was about to say I wasn't
talking about this for nothing right we
can actually I think one thing we want
to check is in the current position can
we play Knight H5 I keep on returning to
this but yeah
I won this bishop gone no but here I'm
scared of C5 again
uh uh DC but we we think yeah first of
all DC but secondly we we currently
don't think this is made right I think
yeah yeah but also due to xc5 here
where's the mate here yeah yeah it comes
back actually so Knight H5 even Queen E8
is a move yeah ah yeah Queen E8 is also
a very important resource in these types
of positions yeah for sure
reestablishing more control over the the
light squares could be very useful no
it's almost this Knight and Bishop
they're really doing a great job
so far
all right so let's maybe let Jeffrey
think what do we think about the London
how's the because the London looked like
it was getting sharper than we the
anticipated versus
yeah this looks like they won't live on
against yeah the one against the end we
left it we thought that white was for
Choice yeah but uh
weird things have happened since Levon
chose a kind of a strange plan he landed
the light on she seeks and seemingly
prepared to support it with before and
B5 and then never played B5 so it is now
sort of stuck on CC not stuck I mean but
it's stuck it's pinned it's spinned and
it's not supported properly by by pawns
so n9d5 is next and 95 is coming in yeah
for sure
but I was trying to make some F5 ideas
work but doesn't look like it I mean
first take on A8 it's an F5 but so what
if you take on A8 and go Queen B2
is kind of Knight E5 95 95 Knight G5 I
guess
you can even start with like D5 yeah
I can also take with f with the F Pawn
Yeah but I can start Knight D5 then
yes yeah we can we can start with this
and also after a frequency EF I have
Queen C3 so I'm I'm actually sort of
playing for a win there maybe maybe I
mean it's it's a draw but black is
completely fine so it looks like Jan is
no pressing is another statement but
yeah I think it's that's the Jeffrey
game pardon me yeah H5 by the way yeah
and uh your take on this one uh Maxine
uh first of all Lanier played incredibly
fast so fast he actually had 27 minutes
on his clock at one moment three moves
ago okay
it was three moves ago now he has 13.
very very usual I'm assuming we are
getting close to a draw but
did Shah win his first two games today
yeah he did he did indeed
nice
and I don't know if you saw the finish
of a Shack's round eight game he had
pawns on C2 and D2 is black yeah that
was some some absolutely against crazy
stuff there at the end
did you see the the ending of that
Christian would you be so kind as to
show our illustrious guest uh this crazy
position we have let's Force this
analyze yeah can we switch off them
before you get to the fight again switch
the engine off and ask mvl what he
thinks about that position sure this is
the this is the this is the way to go
so I think it was somewhere around here
sadly here I just saw the computer
evaluation Oh either draw
but okay so this is this position
how do you win
something else something else
your suggestion of an under promotion is
winning uh Maxine but there is a
remarkable way a bit more dominant that
wins on the spot
not that yeah because the one night King
this way I can understand why this would
not be too Direct
um
I mean
as a kind of a I neither the C1 equals
Queen yeah but like I'm calculating C1
I'm just uh checking whether this
Perpetual or not there it is Perpetual
yeah yes
almost feels like a Twilight Zone oh
yeah because you get mated on this hands
yeah yeah yeah yeah
with the queen on D1 you can still play
Queen to G4 but that's just a draw okay
G4 and Rook C8 so something more direct
it's actually not that directly yeah I
mean it's so yeah no but like more
convincing okay what if I go something
like King gauge 7.
yeah I mean wow
[Laughter]
but yeah this is this is why they're
getting so uh you you can appreciate how
we spend our days uh I mean you know I'm
not jealous per se because I know that
doing commentary is actually quite tough
so I prefer my spots but still yeah it's
not like
you're not doing too badly like there's
good things too so when you're doing
comments one one final game we haven't
spoken about yet the the clash between
Hikaru and Fabi so what do we think
about this position I'm kind of liking
it for I want to say I like it for black
but as usual
the the problem is I can see Christian's
screen
ah you shouldn't be looking I shouldn't
be looking but I have I have sharp eyes
uh wow uh boy it started off as an A3
English uh Max uh Maxine Just Jump Right
In what's your how do you break down
this position what what what draws your
eyes in one room this looks terrible
before
for blackout assume right
I mean terrible for white yeah
thank you I was I was waiting for that
clarification
for white and why do you say that uh
well if you don't have to play G5
then you might be fine but I don't see
like a move like Knight B3 holding up so
I'm assuming that if I will be forced
and then your pieces are just kind of
passive I'm wondering if GTA xc5 is
playable and then E5 against whatever we
play but
yeah but Knight takes already
E5
and just Knight D7 or something or what
do you want here yeah
and then I wanted to maybe take on the
six golden Knight D4 and claim that
we're yeah no maybe maybe this was not
the best
what if I take with a pawn if I'm an id7
yeah this one worries me more
yeah
because I feel like I will have to
sacrifice that pawn but maybe it's not
that bad anyway like Bishop D5 and then
Knight D4 or
Knight D E4 well out of three uh I will
I will choose a square depending on what
okay it's at the very least there are
more content chances than I first
thought so probably with detect C5 like
unless or something but also like the
594 how bad is it or good I've g594
let's say we play
I mean do we have took an ID for I
thought Knight F4 was also a very
serious option
some stuff
including Knight d795 yeah five now can
I go with E5 yeah I was I was wondering
if we can do this yeah the thematics
this Knight D3 is a problem though
I like take on E5 and then I guess I can
go 94. yeah it's not 94 was your idea
but
I don't know I yeah I was guessing I can
just take on me maybe something no it's
a very like in terms of practical terms
it's not that Dreadful unless I have
five so let's see yeah five right let's
see five
yeah because D6 Bishop A5 actually
or maybe pontex C4
yeah this doesn't look good yeah let's
go Knight C5 here E4 E4 yeah this
doesn't look good at all
because Queen D6 Queen D6 coming in and
even E43 if you have to play with pizzas
yeah yeah that's not good
yeah that might be a problem
so at the very least spending time
um whether to play D5 or detect C5 but
it looks pretty bad to be honest
from a practical perspective from a
practical perspective it's not as bad as
I first thought but still
it's bad but not terrible
and Knight B3
idea yeah MP3 is also a move but uh
maybe the sort of the least critical
yeah it just it feels a little grotty
but uh
yeah I didn't want my B3 but
don't know don't know
um overall uh how do you like
the the tournament thus far uh Maxine uh
how your overall feeling three rounds of
Rapid you you've had some some very
exciting games and I'm not sure but I
think it might be the first time I'm
unbeatening the weapons
the first time that you lead in the
rapid yeah it's very likely actually
Maxim congratulations first of all I
mean that's a pretty respectable result
I would say after three rounds still two
more days to go 18 games to go how do
you feel about the blitz section
I'm feeling good like the way I played
so far I feel that if I can keep up this
shape
um I have nothing to be worried about in
terms of GCT standings
given that uh 11 was
you know the main competitor in terms of
points so far the fact that I have a
three points advantage over him maybe
two if you win this game we'll see but
it's quite a good feeling so I'm keeping
an active eye on those GCT standings at
all times
not at all times but I mean definitely
some perspective I mean I would
definitely want to win this event and
like get some sort of advantage over
both live on Wesley and the other
players Maxim congratulations we'll see
you tomorrow thank you question thank
you for joining us Maxine always a
pleasure to have you in studio uh I'm
looking at Sam shanklin's position the
more I'm looking at it I hate it I think
White's position is just Dreadful yeah
he kind of went all in and uh seems like
Jeffrey found a way to to bury at least
the immediate attack and my you know
well first of all we got rid of the
bishop that was that was a success
something I was very much looking
forward to and then we've just we've
just broken the entire structure up as
well right and White's King with this
very last move e uh six E5 yeah
absolutely oh dear so it really does
seem like my my Pearl clutching about
the opening of the a file was
completely incorrect well but it was one
of those things at first when you see it
it's kind of compelling you you go down
that path of creating threats on the
a-file and you get led to a dead end
yeah and it's a dark alley if you will
another thing that I'm wondering uh
looking at this position is if I apart
from just breaking everything open
introduces an additional idea of perhaps
playing Rook H6 if we need to stopping
some Knights C4 Knight takes B6 excuse
me that was uh my bad so yeah it looks
like you're saying it just introduces a
further defensive idea if we ever need
more Defenders on the king side on the
queen H6 might be a very useful idea
agreed this looks like uh boy it just
went it went completely South on uh Sam
uh absolutely what else you got going on
and and the engines definitely agree
with you guys the engines don't agree
with uh mvl's assessment neither maybe
Peter's assessment in this game between
Hikaru and karwana but it's so strange
to uh look at it because after the move
C5 Peter you are feeling that black is
doing perfectly fine right my initial
assessment was yeah I looked at the
position I thought black is doing very
very well and then yeah as I mentioned I
shouldn't really look in that direction
from a practical perspective it does
seem that that was the case because
immediately in three moves d594 Bishop
to E3 Rook to E5 Bishop to E2 already
the computers seem to be catching up and
understand that from a practical
perspective black is actually doing just
fine this is the current position we
have on the board Queen to E7 this Rook
on E5 is doing a mighty job of just
keeping the position Compact and at some
point when you go Knight to F3 I'm just
going to leave the root there I'm going
to give you the exchange I'm going to
have so much control over the dark
squares and so much initiative coming
your way on the king side I really like
from a practical perspective Fabiano's
position in this one
wow nice nice this idea of Knight F3 and
just leaving the room
unfortunately I don't think you know it
might be difficult to realize in
Practical terms not because of Knight
takes C5 threats but because of the
threats to the of the like double
capture on D4 in some in some version
but I think we can actually take one of
three like even though this is even like
93 here is very strong so yeah your
knight G4 move might be might be very
very useful
um
we just took one of three and the point
is after GF we have Knight H5
so we can sort of re-establish control
over the dark squares if we allow F3 F4
here we're obviously very unhappy
exactly but we can play Knight H5 Queen
F6 and sort of re-establish the grip on
the dark squares and uh Hikaru himself
as a king's Indian official you will
understand everything you're doing yes
and and white in response I think you
know if you had time enough for this you
would go something like Queen G2 Bishop
D1 92 on obviously 392 exactly as
yesterday yeah and fight for that yeah
but you probably don't have enough time
for that I would assume black probably
has time to do something about it so
Knight H5 was played answered
immediately
Bishop d392 as we were mentioning uh
this is one of those moments where you
kind of settle uh for Bishop A5 Bishop
takes C3 and somebody says you got this
out of a samish uh yeah Nims out no I
didn't it was an A3 English and by the
way that was a key moment and a golden
opportunity for Hikaru to potentially uh
get the advantage after Queen to D2
at which moment instead of now Bishop to
D3 which he played instantaneously died
h52 now the idea is that and you have to
see this if you play Queen to D2 that
after Queen F6 you are in time to go
Knight D1 Knight F2 with an attack uh
via G4 as well as D3
oh that is so I find just simply not be
in time to defend those pawns on the
king side that's black
yeah I was always thinking of of
fighting for the F4 Square from the e to
square with the Knight and one but
Knight F2 Knight to D3 or Knight to G4
Peter that's a nice that doesn't
surprising way of fighting like a very
nice nice maneuver but also very
miscible minerals very easy by the way
Bishop A5 came quickly by Fabi Anno as
well uh making sure that that night's
not moving yeah after Knight H5 Bishop
D3 I guess question mark uh it was uh
time to play Queen D2 there looks very
very nice for Fabi
um continuing uh what about what's going
on on the Lavon game for just a moment
that might be a draw live one has
already declined an immediate repetition
but it's very difficult to imagine how
white wins this like he he clearly has
the more active Queen but I'm not sure
you can really capitalize on that and in
fact the position is so close that I'm
honestly I think that it's that there
will come a time where Jan will be just
able to play Queen d75 and offer at that
pawn ending it looks ugly but how do you
how do you uh get in you know there will
not be any Lion King
my goodness have they played a lot of
chess with one another uh Peter yeah the
wow
that is a century again that is a lot of
games and the one is
marginally in front there with 34 wins
and 30 losses but yeah not not that you
might have done this yourself but who is
the who is the player you've played the
most games against I did this research I
think that's in my case it's Boris
yeah and I think we've played because
over a hundred games against each other
but I I I've looked I've looked it up
recently and I've to my shame I'm not
100 sure of my answer but uh the
question did come up during uh some kind
of a conversation and I checked the
databases and I still don't remember
anymore
um wow Christian you jumped in who's
been your biggest uh opponent that you
played the most uh games against well I
haven't played someone
tournaments like you guys have uh done
so I don't have any clients my usual
clients like YouTube
um probably some of my youth opponents
right are the ones that I play the most
games against but I just wanted to point
out the fact that right now we might see
a resignation very soon here Sam
Shanklin because if you don't Checkmate
me after Rook days B7 King takes B7 Rook
to A1 if you don't Checkmate me first
you are getting checkmated that's why
for sure D3 is coming queen to F2 is
coming you cannot touch the first rank
with the King because that would allow
my Rook to invade via H1 with a check so
D3 King to D2 Queen to F2 let's just
simply follow it up yeah the simplest of
C3 you have to go up boom boom I can
just simply exchange the queens and be
material up in a completely winning end
game this one is not looking good I
think we might see a resignation from
Sam Shanklin right now he has eight
minutes to try to figure things out but
there's no stopping D3 and the invasion
of the queen via F2
there comes a moment there that you can
just uh assay the uh King and pawn end
game yeah he could have done it with
Czech a few moves ago which would have
really forced the force that engage you
know maybe was a an even a more
straightforward way of doing the same
but yeah it's a it's a good way to a
kind of show to live on that perhaps you
know resistance to the draw is few times
exactly we will assimilate I can get
everything up the board but as soon as I
play I can actually play King I think I
can stay on h8 and H7 squares right I
don't even need to be in the center I'm
pretty sure I can stay in the corner
exactly Shaq winning another game oh my
gosh three for three would be remarkable
where are you Shaq against Lanier
I mean this is becoming uh
well let's erase why were you so sure
it's it's I'm not I'm not but F5 yes if
I've not the 5c4 I guess is uh kind of
critical because absolutely you do need
to start pushing your uh your own trumps
there on the queen on the queen another
three interesting because the Knight
goes to F5 you don't get to go G5 yeah
and also we see 4c3 and here he's he I
think he's indicating the c495 check is
what he is intending to do right
absolutely so we need to spend one more
time let's go B5 yeah B5 G5
yeah oops excuse me that was my mouse
lip it was supposed to be B5 in order to
be able to meet 95 check and keep the
pawn protected G5 C4 C4 well let's go
um
um let's see Queen who's going to be
first yeah queen queen
uh whose King is more exposed
is probably a draw unfortunately
I mean bugging me is a mild
understatement ouch yeah
so yeah it looks like maybe Blick is
surviving this King F2 maybe is but King
F2 like you you really have to trust in
your 93 yeah like or queen C2 first and
then 93 I might lose
right so I think in the end we go rookie
one allow Rook D1 and then we don't win
because
because we need six checks and 95s Queen
E8 I think with the queen on C1 in
particular taking away some of the
squares from which the checks can be
given I think right I will go towards B7
B6 those types of squares I don't think
I get mated there and you're confident
yeah well no not very confident uh well
okay well that was a line that uh sure
was a challenge uh Christian Jump Right
In And so perhaps after C3 so let's go
through that line sorry that was
supposed to be five again for G6 C3
let's try to stop that pawn with Rook to
E2
Rook to eating
makes sense
how do you continue now Rook no
um
uh King
in order to play Rook d8 uh Peter
King C6
yes you can definitely try to do that
Knight of D4
I'm not like I'm not happy the star is
getting very very scary now well
especially as my pawns are being
blockaded and that's the problem and we
have a lot of time to go H4 H5 no your
Rook E2 is an excellent excellent move
uh Christian that just yikes and yeah
the the help the current problem for
shock is that the g-pawn is surprisingly
difficult to stop with the with the
pieces that he has so
and it's difficult year has not played
B5 yet by the way linear has to solve
all of those puzzles with two minutes on
his clock
that's very very 30-minute challenge
this is not easy absolutely
and if Jack wins this one is he actually
going to be in contention for first well
he he was dead last I think he will be
on 50 so it's not as spectacular as all
that but it's a fantastic recovery from
the absolute base yeah yeah the
horrendous tournament he was having up
until today well those double points you
know that's really hitting a trampoline
you know six out of six
uh but after Knight F3 I I'll have to
defer your defer to yourselves he's got
93 but I still don't really understand
how we're meeting G5 this is the problem
because our pieces continue being very
very ill-equipped to dealing with this
person just continuous continuous
running the setup with Knight on F3 and
a rook and E4 is just unbelievably
annoying and it's very easy to play for
white right you go yeah absolutely
you're from 60 to go h4s you don't even
have to think about things very much no
no no no no it just plays a plays itself
yeah so maybe the counter chance for
black is to try to do Rook to C6 Rook D6
H4 Rook C6 and then try to go for C4
is that it C6 that might make sense that
should never be fast enough we do have a
they did get the Kings to G1 and A8 and
so on so they they had some fun with
this position but yeah we knew that ball
ending wasn't very exciting
absolutely and again uh we're just
saying that Lanier uh clock is ticking
he didn't make a move G4 no 93 and Chuck
is thinking
he will play G5 because there's really
absolutely no reason not to and one of
the largest problems for uh following
year there is that fg5 Rook F5 we can
still play uh G6 so yeah G56 blitzed out
and then you can easily place out H yeah
you play H4 and yeah you have to return
to return maybe he wants to go Rook E6
maybe that's his chance maybe he wants
to go Rook E6 and try to get the king
closer to somehow I like that to the
pawns I wouldn't trade I think if we
traded to draw I think we play Rook G4
here and we try to push while the
bushing is good yeah exactly exactly and
it sure does look like uh the pushing is
I can also try to gain another Tempo
with Rook A4
yeah by the way we are breaking not a
surprise for ourselves but Sam Shanklin
did lose with white against Jeffrey Jean
so despite them having diametrically
opposite days up until that moment the
person who was on zero out of two today
actually convincingly beats the person
who was
right yeah some will be disappointed
with this after beating to incredibly
strong players with the white pieces
yeah to lose with white himself uh it
will be will be quite unpleasant for him
and it does seem like Fabiano is also
um but he's assuming some stripes in his
game against assuming control let's see
when we left it we were up about here
well wait a minute that H pawns get to
H3
yeah so probably broke broke the on the
green side with B5 and now we have the
sun game where white has the bishop pair
but that Knight on F4 is an unbelievably
strong and also importantly black has
all the play on The Queen side with like
Rook B3 rookie B8 rugby two ideas on uh
on that side I think you want to try to
consolidate with something like Bishop 3
King F2 perhaps King G3 will be
eventually an idea so black doesn't have
infinite time you you still have you've
got to go you still have to pay
attention but right
um
I assume there is enough play on The
Queen side here somehow to to generate
uh unpleasant breakthrough like Rook B3
I think is a very good start I have 53
provoking something like hook C1 and now
we play Rook fb8 and or Bishop C2 is no
longer really an option Rook p8 or
rookie which one electric B8 because I
think there's no comfortable reply to it
Bishop C4 doesn't look very good and it
might be required honestly yeah this
this starts looking like
but I know you said it didn't look good
but I'm really happy that the bishop
which was on B1 found a miracle Square
yeah but I'm I'm thinking on G2 playing
Rook B2 here I think which is this is
still going to be quite uh it's it's our
play on Logo you still feel like it
takes takes push performance page five
like it's it continues being unpleasant
all the way through right I I should be
three played so we'll see what Fabi
thinks about can I use D1 instead of
Bishop takes F4
but you do have king of two right so
it's not it's not that clear yeah Rook
D1
defending the mission yeah maybe you
have Chief Bishop H5 king king of two
Knight G6
and put it and put it on E5
but I'm still I feel like I'm kicking in
this case though yeah I don't think
white is helpless but you're also a bit
tied down the problem is yeah
295 and I want to play F7 F6 and yeah
black is kind of chilling here right
like F6 King F7 I don't know how I will
make any significant progress but if I
will struggle to make constructive moves
yeah eventually I do need to release my
pieces yeah but that much takes a 394
check will be something you might have
to be very careful not to blunder
through that yeah I don't want a blunder
it's not a fun position for a wife
tough I feel a little bit uh tied up no
question about that okay we'll keep our
eye on that again uh
so there's another one already made a
draw we've got two remaining games this
one this one and the the pawn race in
Miami jar of Dominguez and I think even
optically you can very easily see which
side is currently ahead in the race A6
H5 on the board this is not going to be
fun for following year to hold on very
very little time yeah
like if you have to just sort of brace
for impact and play 95. it's a kind of a
strange feeling because like if you're
wrong about this you're just lose right
if the sun game is lost it's lost
immediately he's not going for 95 yeah I
think it's very very difficult route G4
C4 and just trust in this right just
trust that this holds I don't think
Lanier has had that trust yeah he's gone
he's gone King E7 which is also very
understandable he wants this King to you
know fight against the pawns but yeah
get the key in front of the G6
G4
you don't have King G7 the problem yeah
exactly I can show an H6 check is sort
of uh that's immediate ggs I think
that's bad news of course but King says
I get that but just a second here I
don't have to walk into no King G7 H6 so
you want to go 95. is this absolutely
terrible Peter I don't know I was trying
to figure it out yeah take Stakes I
thought I was winning here but H6 Rook
H5 exists right exactly okay H5 Rook F4
King G8 it's I think this is actually
fine for the remarkable
I think why does she needs to be careful
yeah you don't want to blow that one
but just you well I mean for Lanier I
mean he's puts his King back on
G8 and he just hopes for the best uh
you could of course carefully
uh push those pawns up the board it
didn't have to be
so what's the cleverest way to try and
do this with white
exactly
there's one good thing about this Knight
on D3
and stops that Rook as is prevents The
Rook from freezing the king and blocks
off the by far the best Square on the
board for for that Rook yes hugely
hugely important here one thing I have
to say is that linear did find the most
testing way exactly the same game
because we saw so many Force lines that
were just ending badly for him yeah Rook
G4 first by by Shah I guess we can play
King fate or King F7 I don't know if
there's a big probably a fate is the
more more prudent
wait I like that if you go to F7 I go G6
right yeah this is why I didn't want to
do that he goes 95 straight in this case
he goes 95. yeah so we know takes things
G6 is likely to be a draw so let's try
takes takes H6 maybe King F7 again no
king of Fate yeah king of Fate king of
Fate anyway might be the same position
yeah somehow it's a trend
might be the same position
is he going to hold this on a minute
that's going to be a very very
impressive by by the year
holds this
you know when you think about uh having
a challenging position and to yeah he
might be with little time to find the
secrets
yeah and also his play has become much
much simpler because yeah like yo your
first first and foremost task for you
here is not to allow the pawns to to get
to the queening square and in most cases
your choices will be extremely forced
for you so exactly
by the way I just noticed on your board
that uh Fabi and ikaro seem to be
heading right towards that position not
exactly it's it's a slightly different
version of the the same because uh Fabi
didn't play rugby three when we were
expecting him to play Rook B3 and now
he's well Rooks aren't as connected as
uh we were hoping they will be here and
Lanier uh G6 H6
they're going to reach the exact
position that we yeah you can't really
do anything else any like King G8 might
not be losing by force but why would you
ever not exactly Rook H5 he's done it
yeah
so G actually this is some kind of a
study isn't it I mean
H5 yes
well we've got to go C4 right with Rook
D6
King no okay
oh we don't hold this actually yeah
we've it's successfully we've
successfully lost this
continue we could do it it was actually
the owner yeah
instead of Rook H5 our you know praised
Rook H5 was losing on the spot yeah so
it was King G8 fantastic fantastically
played by all of us yeah wow yeah chess
is a cruel game I mean the fact that he
had reached this position and almost
saved it King G8 would have saved the
game Christian yes yes
that one
so nice yeah and this now is just a very
very uh tree really lost before yeah
shark goes three for three huh what a
day
shot goes three for three and here he
goes
and that's all she wrote that's a good
day at the office for Shaq
that's for sure yeah King F2 that's okay
wow
six points up for grabs Christian and he
grabbed them all absolutely absolutely
no sharing he's not sharing other
anymore
wow he wasn't three out of 12. he was
now a 9 out of 18 which is quite
respectable again he was at three out of
12. yes
3 out of 12. yes that's just horrifying
then nine out of 18. boy he'll sleep
well tonight yeah he'll be
he'll be
and uh your your your need your take on
the game between Hikaru and Fabi is Fabi
dominating or is it
I think it's probably reasonably finely
balanced because I don't know how we're
breaking through
so let's put the King on E5 yeah
we put the pawn on F5
I don't know if I want to play F5 not
very not immediately I think we kind of
if we ever play F5 we need to prepare it
properly because it will give the white
pieces some air as well it's not just
breaking up the center it also provides
some oxygen for well I'm just saying if
White
I've just put these by the way uh it
seems like there's a storm above us uh
uh
[Music]
raining raining like the devil here in
St Louis we've had gorgeous weather up
until exactly this moment Mother Nature
should have waited about 20 more minutes
okay we would have been fine sorry you
didn't want to play F5 I'm not sure I
don't see anything particularly wrong
with it I just feel like maybe it would
not you know it would not harm to to do
some more so for example F5 I think I
can take right on f52.
and very quickly Rook G1 different
approach this is very strong and I think
it may have also been
uh
missed by uh by Fabi because the the G5
Pawn is now hanging and yes the Rook is
coming to G4 if you if you decide to
correct your mistake and go King F6 and
if you go F6 if you go Bishop takes a
four might just be kind of made yeah or
I mean an extra piece at least yeah
which before so let's look at that yeah
he has yeah check king of five F4 check
and if you think
if you take 24 you get mated in the
center nice
nicely done wait where's the mate what
wait what king of five oh sorry um
it's late it's late yeah exactly but
that was nice uh what did he do after
Rook G1 by the way he won King F6 and
Hikaru does not play Rook G4 he played
King G3
which also looks extremely logical but
we want to take this Knight and drive
you home yeah okay four is a clever
little uh interpretation here yeah
forcing the bishop to some less than
ideal squares you would like the
playfish perform but that allows Knight
takes D5 which is maybe something that
got missed in the in Translation there
oh this uh lurking bishop and Bishop A2
just looks ugly so he he I mean I'm sure
he knows Bishop Knight takes D5 exists
but he just didn't like putting the
bishop on A2 so yeah he goes Bishop of
195 Bishop C1 but that obviously is an
achievement for Fabi even if the pawn on
H3 now gets picked up he's won something
for it indeed that looked like it was
dead I'm still actually playing like the
four now I think I want to play Knight
to four and push for the 65 breaks
anything anything to be suggested for
Rook B3 actually yeah nothing is hanging
why am I moving this Knight anywhere
yeah but he went back he does go Knight
F4 I think it's a very human reaction
just trying to make sure that you didn't
blunder it you don't forget it's there
and suddenly you know the Rook leaves
the C2 Square I understood we've all
been there on night F4 Christian jumped
right in uh times uh what's going on
only one minute for Fabiano three
minutes and 30 seconds for Hikaru and it
doesn't seem like Fabiano after he took
the pawn on D5 seems to be doing quite
well that move that you mentioned Peter
looked to G4 that would have given a
wide the advantage instead of King to G3
uh what what what uh should he instead
of King Jr of G4 was Stronger 24 was a
big move a big moment no more Rook to A4
Shenanigans you're not in time uh to do
that I think the difference is we'll
have Bishop takes G5 check if you player
okay four here I think we can just play
Bishop one but compared to the game if
you take on D5 I will have Bishop takes
G5 check and I will be exactly
indifferent to the United States exactly
exactly makes all the difference in the
world well well spotted so now once
again it is white who needs to be
careful foreign
this was the big Miss
uh he Carl has really not been firing on
someone thanks H3 played we can play d65
straight away we can also try some other
things can you think
D5 yeah D5 G5 is just very very logical
but breaking everything open and using
the moment to continue
exactly uh cashing in on the pin on the
road constitute and as the position gets
more and more simplified it's much
easier to play also for the player
without that much time which is Fabiano
and he definitely loves to see that
yeah yeah no I think he's just in
control and uh a minute here is a much
more comfortable proposition just as
Christian is saying uh compared to the
position five moves ago where uh
you felt like you weren't as much in
control as I think you are uh here well
that point on D5 was quite an important
yeah yeah like like very important I I'm
trying to exploit the fact that this
night on
F4 is only defended by uh so you want to
push with four for some kind of H4 H2
yes yes precisely you you you picked up
exactly where I was a blunder even E3
yeah yeah
um all right well the clock
the clock is about to get the equalized
you know if the car is only half a
minute ahead now
become a factor so I would assume you
have to take on F4 right now
and then yeah but it's such a hateful
move I understand why I haven't made it
like you just you just every fiber of
your being is telling you yeah please
please don't make me do this yeah right
also after you take C4 like what's the
next move yeah
so he's trying to kind of Sammy Bluff
that's H4 is a very strong threat right
very interesting yes he wants to go back
he wants to go Rook F2 next yes
as well as as well as yeah
okay so is there anything to be said
about King to E5 starting with King to
E5 King King
that looks exciting very cultured but I
think it's very difficult to avoid Rook
takes E4 yeah rookie four Rook F2 and
now
wait a minute three exists rugby one
exists uh if we wanted to
just creating this kind of a kind of
annoying yeah if you play H4 there I
think I could just sidestep it with King
G7 and then Knight G3 will become a
massive massive threat oops
yeah Rook B3 I think is sort of more
logical and more expected I mean I don't
know about more logical but attacking
the C3 Pawn was checkers
there's a very very logical continuation
here Bishop Z2 played now we can now we
have time to play King King G7 or King
E5 whichever one we
we like best
it's funny uh two very attractive moves
King G7 King E5 uh did choose the move
King E5
I don't know that Kings I wanted I
wanted actually to hide it me too King
G7 I thought I think maybe this was a
three Bishop three may have been missed
I I know I missed it it's not really a
huge problem we can play Rook C4 if
things really go horribly we can
sacrifice that exchange on C3 we will be
completely safe always but rookie one
Checker okay one check yeah this is
maybe why we wanted to hide the king
yeah
but I mean it's going to be reasonably
safe on D6 I don't think we are you know
in any kind of a panic mode yet King D6
we can put the Knight on D3 we can play
as I keep on mentioning like if as a
kind of a bailout what takes you through
will always exist and black never ever
loses after that but perhaps it's not
the most winning attempt of all
got it but currently my G3 I guess is
the biggest threat
like you say You're really trying to
force me to take on C3 I will say I will
actually take on C3 there I think on C3
take take
ff1 is hikaru's Choice sidestepping the
fork you know side stepping side
stepping those threads it's all about
the time right now yeah 30 seconds for
Fabiano
G1
and now the king the king needs to get
this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah alert
alert alert I think I think we can sort
of go round about to good school exactly
a king E7 if you get checked it goes
back to 600 and then the G7 where we
wanted to Hideaway a long time ago
that's it you know admittance so right
perhaps a slight mistake earlier like
but sometimes uh being frisky and
Footloose induces our opponent a minute
10 against 36 seconds
but five is in control now we're looking
out of the center and back on reasonably
safe squares you you you no longer
really worry about much this is another
aspect to chess as well uh nerves nerves
play a very crucial role especially when
you're feeling the effects of time
trouble how how about yourself uh Peter
were you uh
good you you didn't I even panic
very much depends on my sort of General
uh general con condition and the form
I'm in in
a particular tournament because I
sometimes I'm an absolute nervous wreck
on on low time and sometimes I feel like
I'm reasonably in control and I don't
have to worry about very much I see and
Bishop H5 chosen by 5B I think in
general we are very much like the idea
of trading those Bishops is
also Rook takes C2 right now is becoming
a real thing I think now narok D2 is a
threat but I think he just wants to get
those Bishops off the board put the
Knight on these six and like everything
is under control everything is protected
yes and then with the extra Pawn to
boost
and a sicaro who is lower on time right
now yeah and uh probably for the first
time in ages is actually uh ahead on the
clock here which page five night page
five king of three and the whole Knight
g76 once again yeah routine I'm I'm I'm
all for that the Knight on E6 will be
it's your perfect it's a good Square
yeah it's definitely a good Square Rook
H4 is another thing that sort of comes
to mind but I really dislike the idea of
G5 and C5 not being protected which is
why I'm so drawn to the idea of putting
that on G7 he's going he does go Rooker
he does go Rook H4 yeah okay
it's a very concrete very aggressive
move because H if H2 Falls the game is
over because the the pawn pair will just
win Rook C8 played by Fabi oh sorry by
Hikaru the idea is Rook H2 Rook C6 check
and then you G5 win either the G5 Pawn
or the to this but now you have to
calculate the Checkmate yeah
Rook H3 check if King G4 I think he's
just trying to gain time right he'll
have to give a check back right he'll
have to give a check from which was a he
did not gain very much I think G5 G4
might be very strong but he hasn't
played it yet like in the current
position I think G5 G4 might be very
very promising
I must say wow because we're forcing the
king to the second I think and then it
might just tactically be unfeasible to
defend
well uh Rook H4 might be one of those
Rook takes H2 Rook C6 will be played I
think he wants to go King G7 and then
start giving mate like give a check from
F2 and then go after the king yeah so
King seven Bishop G5 only move otherwise
you're just gonna resign uh yeah if you
don't take one G5 your position is just
straight up hopeless so you have to kind
of close your eyes and just take right
just hope for the best yeah and hope
that they're nothing nothing bad happens
to a King and it really doesn't seem
like much bad will happen to your king
because it runs towards like E4 e45
right looks like the worst has maybe
again that move Rook H4 was a surprising
one for me because Knight G7 Knight E6
you just centralized the Knight you
cover everything and then you start
picking up some wikis yeah this is
well not convincing maybe I'm wrong but
uh
yeah this this feels like it might be it
might be manageable Knight G3 checks we
go to D3 don't go to D5 yeah we can't go
forward because we will lose the bishop
but King D3 seems to be completely fine
yeah King G3 King C4
actually King D3 is also losing to Rook
at five five uh briefly I will switch it
off so that we don't get distracted King
E3 strictly the only Square on the board
that doesn't lose E3 I don't know how
easy that is King G3 Rooker five there's
no defense against Rook D5 check and by
the way Hikaru Sans says that something
could be a Miss yeah absolutely okay
Rooker five wins now the game ends if
you find Rooker five wow because you've
got the double threat of Rook takes G5
as well as Rook D5 I think it's findable
simply because Rook of three King C4
just doesn't look very promising I don't
think you want to be moving the king
towards those squares exactly even
though even even though I think what
might lead Fabi down the H5 it's similar
yeah
oh no no don't take C5
Roxy 5 is now move yeah yeah if you see
Rook H5 it's difficult it's it's weird
that you see Rook H5 but not Rook F5
okay so right
Rook C5 Rook F3 there should be three as
well because the Rook on H2 wasn't
hanging it will be hanging on F2 so even
Bishop E3 is now a move Rook D5 checking
C4 and we just trade Rooks that's
exactly the best move because if you
take on C5 Rook F3 followed by Knight E4
it might be a problem
so Rook F3 where do you put the king D4
I think but then maybe Knight E2 is
strong yeah Rook of three and now he has
no like he has to go forward if King
c294 is just hopeless no but if you go
King to D4 I have Rook F5
yeah I mean you do but like how easy is
that yeah
King D4 before Knight to five check I
guess is
15 seconds yeah Rooker five does win but
it's okay it's such an unusual Motif
Rook F5 it is such an unusual mode
Bishop E7 it should be seven as well
like you've
is now back to being completely winning
exactly King H7 just keep that PIN
or rookie five check and then something
King H7 just keeping that pin alive
that's what he's done yeah
this is now a reasonably comfortably
winning for black Rook d8 or Rook D7
somewhere that's it King E3
you still you still have to win this
position but I'm yeah Rook H3 and then
something yeah King E4 I assume by
thinking it do you want to play ayaking
for Rook h4o64 like if all else fails we
can we can do that keep looking on E3
and try to create some kind of but now
F5 just wins the piece right a five F4
check exactly that's that's a five or
four check wins the bishop on detail so
the game is if if I replays of five here
I think the game is over
key moment how much time left Chris is
38 seconds
yeah that should probably be quite easy
um uh F5 C5 F4 I take you take take King
E5 no no never fast enough
King G6 yeah I mean yeah I think this is
checking because yeah he needs to just
double checking and Hikaru is showing
some disgust
uh Hikaru is not impressed but I mean
wow it was a very swingy game I have to
say but yeah C5 and yeah he's going to
he's going to Bluff this being a draw
but it's not a draw it's actually I
think it's a one tempo game there it is
a one Temple someone shockingly this is
a one Temple game but it's it's enough
yeah
one tempo is all you need it's enough
my kingdom for a Tempo Peter
so let's just go down the Primrose path
King takes place King E5 yeah six yes C6
king of seven
oops excuse me yeah and Kikar just
resigns and
is done with this yeah she said wow
and we're just in time to stop thinking
from getting to D7
whoo
a very very eventful day absolutely how
many wins in this last round uh you know
today I think I think we may have had
more decisive results today than in the
previous two days combined I'm pretty
sure well I mean I'm thinking in round
nine we had three wins three wins three
wins and in round eight we also had I
believe three wins three wins so whoo
but uh let's jump to Christian who is
um guesting uh chakrian mamidarov a
three out of three Shaq a perfect score
in the final day of Rapid chess you
started off slowly this event but today
you were just a completely different man
what did you do last night in
preparation for this uh these games
[Music]
of course it's a certain normal for me
is to lose three games to win three
games you know and just try to play good
interesting chess and today I played
interesting chess Fighting Chess like it
lasts two days but it was very bad
results uh
but today okay maybe it was very
interesting games if you were
interesting games and I won three games
in Royal no secret it's just it's my
style absolutely let's talk about this
last game because you guys were blitzing
out all the way until I think move 20
plus
did you guys both of you know this uh
theoretical Battle of course this move
Knight E7 is opening is not
a main move it's uh yeah yeah 97
normally people play Knight F6 but it's
a problem I want to play this move for
myself and some sometimes and for this
reason I analyzed also this Knight G5
line I know 97 it looks like is just I
mean Knight F6 that everyone played 97
nobody play but not G5 you play all the
line first lines I think and it is the
engine show is like
very close to draw
um but yeah very close but I just played
this move Rook f8 I mean it's surprised
for
the means yeah I mean look of faith I
think is maybe his first line is like
Rook D5 is draw I mean look D5 but okay
I mean I just play very first look of
Faith position of course it looks like
draw not draw is less equal position but
the end game is two points it's just
let's speak about the end games because
it feels like this one as well as the
game against Jeffrey also you had uh
quite an important attempt against
Hikaru in that end game as well you are
enjoying these grindy end games this
tournament no I think the problems no I
I I I I absolutely I I don't want to
play in games it's uh I'm not very happy
with when I play End games but when okay
uh when okay you just said Hikaru
Jeffrey today I mean I just like to play
better in games if you're better in the
game I like play but if I need a defense
I don't like this one for this reason in
in these three games I just attack in
game I just play two results and it was
easy to play you know it's I mean one
extra Pawn against the Hikaru and
Jeffrey after the opening of course
everyone want to play this any games
absolutely and uh just to go back
towards the end of this game at this
point after age six he still had the
draw with the smooth King to ga yeah of
course I I think yeah yeah but for this
I I calculate this but what what I can
do I mean ah I heard some maybe another
idea but I think King Jade I can play G7
it's same idea
yeah and then
okay I don't know why I played very fast
these moves but this looks winning
position because two pawns is very
strong but I I just calculated it's like
winning position somewhere but that's my
mistake yes maybe it's not winning
because how to improve my chance yeah
now that easy road to C8 C4 is coming
yeah Shaq 18 games what's your routine
been like this tournament what do you do
after you finish games okay I mean first
of all not easy tournament every day is
very good very interesting chess and of
course relaxing and just
uh to try to some relax I don't know uh
you know okay you can
almost every day every game and for this
reason I just injured from chess it's
rules or win is okay I just play next
game and okay I mean it's very strong
tournament what I can say and just
relaxing and preachers take it one game
at a time enjoy the games that seems
like solid advice thank you very much
Jack we'll see you tomorrow thank you
congratulations uh Shaq from ourselves
that was very very fun and very and the
the secret dream game play End Game Play
very very succinctly
expressed there by just always be better
in end game yeah and then you can enjoy
it the extra Pawn yeah very very
meaningful and here's our current
standings after the rapid we have a tie
for the rapid Chess Championship
absolutely with the two Frenchmen up
there at the top on 11 out of 18. a
seven clear third despite losing in
round nine right and then a type for uh
for fourth between
who's had a poor day today frankly and
resurging
Resurgence of shockyard clearly the
story of the day and the Americans World
Hall of Fame at the bottom of the table
there uh what's going on with Pappy
Lavon lunir and Hikaru oh boy yeah but
they I think they will enjoy the shorter
the shorter time controls starting from
Tomorrow absolutely and where is where
it is
18 and Blitz Games at that come on
Hikaru uh
final thoughts uh for the broadcast
Christian what happened all I have to
say it was another incredible day of
Rapid trust still shocking to me is to
see Hikaru at the bottom of the
standings he's just not been himself I
have to say Fabiano Carona that was the
battle between him and uh Hikaru in the
last round Fabiano started with two
losses that was a very very difficult
path for him and to win with the black
pieces against Hikaru that's never an
easy task such a nerve-wracking game
that was that definitely puts him back
on a more positive path going into the
Blitz game definitely will be a
spectacle of Fast and Furious just in
the next couple of days guys thank you
Chris after that and Peter we're getting
her gonna enjoy ourselves as we get
prepared for Blitz tomorrow thank you
everyone for sharing uh your weekend
with us join us for tomorrow same time
same channel and we will be playing nine
rounds of Blitz
two days in a row so stay tuned and it
will be fun this was fun but compared to
the the next two days this was kind of
slow and meditative you know exactly no
no more good night everyone see you then
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited